bonjour à tous
mes chers collègues nous avons l'honneur
de recevoir aujourd'hui Monsieur
François Fillon ancien Premier ministre
monsieur le Premier ministre je vous
remercie d'avoir répondu à notre
convocation et de vous être rendu
disponible pour nos travaux comme vous
le savez Monsieur le Premier Ministre
notre commission travaille depuis
plusieurs mois et c'est sa dernière
semaine d'audition sur les tentatives ou
les réalités d'ingérence de puissance
étrangères dans la vie politique
économique française ainsi que ses
ingérences auprès des relais d'opinion
de notre pays qui pourraient avoir une
influence sur nos concitoyens et sur
notre démocratie à ce titre notre
commission s'est intéressée à la
question des recrutements ou des
collaborations professionnelles entre
des anciens aux responsables politiques
ou des hauts fonctionnaires par des
entreprises étrangères liées de près ou
de moins à des régimes étrangers souvent
des régimes
autoritaires voire des dictatures le cas
de l'ancien chancelier allemand garage
Schroeder
et emblématique sur des questions qui
ont pu poser problème et de graves
problèmes dans la mise sous dépendance
de l'Europe et des pays européens des
approvisionnements en gaz russe
vous avez Monsieur le Premier Ministre
une longue carrière de responsable
politique français à tous les échelons
de notre démocratie jusqu'à l'une des
plus éminentes Premier ministre vous
avez été amené leur cadre de vos
fonctions à rencontrer à plusieurs
reprises votre homologue alors Vladimir
Poutine à l'époque Premier ministre de
Dimitri medwnef qui était lui-même à
l'époque président de la Fédération de
Russie entre 2008 et 2012 vous avez
selon toute apparence et je tiens à
préciser sans que ce soit un reproche de
la part de notre commission qui n'est
pas une instance judiciaire maintenue
des relations avec la Russie après 2012
en 2021 vous avez été notamment nommé au
conseil d'administration de deux
importantes sociétés russes le groupe
pétrolier zarubazeneff et le groupe de
petrochimie SIBUR c'est de vous avez
démissionner ensuite de ces deux postes
au lendemain de l'agression militaire
russe contre l'Ukraine nous souhaitons
monsieur le Premier ministre et c'est
l'objet de cette convocation comprendre
votre vision
non seulement des relations entre la
France et la Russie mais surtout votre
appréciation des de la réalité ou des
tentatives d'ingérence des puissances
étrangères envers la France en
particulier les tentatives du régime
russe d'influencer notre démocratie nous
souhaitons recueillir votre témoignage
sur votre expérience personnelle et
aussi sur cette expérience
professionnelle nous souhaitons
comprendre comment et pourquoi vous avez
accepté d'exercer ses fonctions et
comment et pourquoi vous avez souhaité
les CC cette audition monsieur le
Premier ministre et retransmise en
direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale l'enregistrement vidéo sera
ensuite sera ensuite disponible à la
demande elle est bien sûr ouverte à la
presse monsieur premier je vous propose
de vous laisser la parole pour une
intervention pour liminaire d'une
quinzaine de minutes sur les thèmes qui
vous les ont été communiqués évidemment
si vous avez besoin de plus de temps
pour exposer votre propos vous pouvez la
voir nous poursuivons ensemble nos
échanges par des questions de votre
serviteur de madame la rapporteur
constance le gris et des différents
commissaires présents je vous rappelle
monsieur Premier ministre au titre de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires les
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête doivent prêter le
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité aussi je vous
invite monsieur le Premier ministre à
lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure
je vous remercie et vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président je ne vais pas
vous imposer 15 minutes de au polymère
parce que je pense que le plus
utile et que je réponde aux questions
que vous souhaitez me poser je veux
juste faire trois remarques
avant de commencer à répondre à vos
questions la première pour dire que j'ai
siégé dans cette assemblée pendant 22
ans que j'ai siégé trois ans au Sénat et
que j'ai été membre du gouvernement de
la République pendant 12 ans
à aucun de ces moments jamais pendant
ces 36 années je crois de vie publique
on a pu trouver
une seule action de ma part qui soit
influencer par une puissance étrangère
j'ai toujours défendu l'intérêt national
en tout cas tel que je le conçois et
cette attitude n'a pas changé la
deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que j'ai des convictions qui n'ont
pas varié notamment sur cette question
de du rapport entre la France et la
Russie
pourrait résumer ses convictions en
disant qu'elles sont gaullistes mais
immédiatement je vois les ricanements
n'ont pas ici naturellement mais à
l'extérieur arrivé en disant que tout ça
c'est du passé et que
le monde a changé c'est vrai que le
monde a changé que la situation est une
différente aujourd'hui de celle que nous
avons connues mais il y a une chose qui
a pas changé et qui au fond était le la
base du de la vision qui était celle du
général de Gaulle en politique étrangère
c'est la géographie
nous sommes sur le même continent que la
Russie et une immense partie de la
Russie est européenne
on peut aimer pas aimer combattre être
en désaccord il y a bien des raisons
d'être en désaccord avec le régime russe
et pas seulement avec celui-là mais avec
tous ceux que la Russie a connu depuis
bien longtemps ça n'efface pas cette
constatation que la proximité de la
Russie et de notre pays et de l'Europe
oblige à trouver des un mode de relation
avec la Russie qui permettent d'assurer
la paix et la sécurité
c'est d'ailleurs ces convictions qui
m'ont conduit à m'intéresser à ces taux
à la Russie puisque j'y effectué mon
premier déplacement à la tête d'une
délégation parlementaire de la
Commission de la Défense nationale et
des forceuses armées dont j'étais le
président en 1986 ou 87 je ne souviens
plus très bien mais je pense que c'était
en 1986 et c'était une mission assez
historique enfin sans exagération
puisque c'était la première fois que la
Commission de la Défense nationale se
rendait dans le pays qui était notre
adversaire principal
j'y suis retourné d'ailleurs l'année
suivante ou
1988 cette fois-ci en étant dans
l'opposition avec Jean-Pierre
Chevènement que vous avez auditionné il
y a quelques instants
Jean-Pierre Chevènement a effectué une
visite en Union soviétique dans les
forces armées soviétiques en 1988 et il
avait souhaité que je l'accompagne pour
démontrer ou pour montrer aux Russes que
en matière de défense
il n'y avait pas de division à
l'intérieur de notre pays et que nous
étions que nous étions solidaires
la troisième et dernière remarque que je
veux faire elle concerne mon expérience
des ingérences étrangères
est-ce que j'ai rencontré dans ma vie
politique et en particulier lorsque
j'étais au gouvernement des ingérences
étrangères oui j'en ai rencontré
la plupart du temps elle venait d'un
pays ami et allié qui s'appelle les
États-Unis
je porte pas de jugement je dis
votre commission travaille sur les
ingérences étrangères je vous dis que
par exemple j'ai été écouté avec le
président Sarkozy pendant 5 ans par la
NSA
on l'assume lorsque
des documents des services secrets
américains ont futé et tout le monde
s'est fixé sur le fait que le NSA
écoutait Madame Merkel enfin il écoutait
aussi l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement français sans doute des
autres pays européens d'ailleurs une
pratique assez généralisée parmi les
grandes puissances mais il y a une
ingérence américaine qui me pose
problème et que je considère comme la
plus sérieuse
quant à ses conséquences sur
la vie économique de notre pays c'est
la le principe d'extéritorialité de la
justice américaine qui permet
à la justice américaine est souvent
l'administration américaine d'intervenir
au mépris de mon point de vue des
principes du droit international dans
les affaires des entreprises européennes
c'est systématique
savait commencer avec
comme prétexte pour intervenir
l'utilisation du dollar ce qui m'avait
d'ailleurs conduit
avant 2016 à proposer une réforme
profonde de de
la monnaie européenne pour qu'elles
deviennent une monnaie internationale
désormais c'est sans doute la monnaie
chinoise qui deviendra la monnaie
internationale concurrente de la monnaie
américaine mais maintenant ce n'est même
plus la question du dollar qui sert de
prétexte que les Américains ont voté des
lois
entre guillemets sur la corruption qui
leur permet d'intervenir dans n'importe
quel condition sur la vie des
entreprises européennes et j'ai été
particulièrement concerné par
l'amende de 9 milliards d'euros qui
avait été imposé à la Banque Nationale à
la BNP
dans des conditions de mon point de vue
tout à fait anormal puisque il
s'agissait de sanctionner des
financements que la BNP avait apporté à
des entreprises ou à des opérations au
Soudan alors que le Soudan faisait
l'objet d'aucune sanction de la part des
autorités françaises ou des autorités
américaines
j'ai été confronté à d'autres
exemples d'ingérence
l'espionnage chinois peut-être vous
souvenez-vous d'une affaire
retentissante ou une délégation de haut
niveau
d'officier le Chinois avaient en
visitant Airbus placé des clés
USB pour récupérer des informations sur
des ordinateurs
et puis j'ai été confronté même si ça
n'est pas la même dimension mais c'est
peut-être plus proche encore de votre
sujet
à des ingérences venant de pays comme la
Turquie
le Maroc
l'Algérie qui donne directement des
consignes de vote au moment des
élections françaises par l'intermédiaire
de responsable religieux
j'ai pas été concerné directement par
des ingérences russes ça veut pas dire
qu'il y en a pas naturellement et bien
sûr qu'il y en a
la Russie comme toutes les grandes
puissances
tentent de faire prévaloir son point de
vue elle le fait souvent d'une façon
assez grossière qui de mon point de vue
n'a pas une très grande efficacité mais
en ce qui me concerne et je devais vous
le dire en commençant cette séance je
n'ai pas été directement concerné par
ces ingérences russes
voilà je vais m'arrêter là parce que je
pense que le mieux c'est que je réponde
à toutes vos questions qui j'imagine
sont nombreuses
merci Monsieur prémices ma première
question et je me limiterai à quelques
questions puisqu'il y a nombreux
commissaires et j'aimerais que tout le
monde puisse avoir le temps de poser ces
questions vous venez de de parler des
ingérences étrangères venant de Russie
vous avez indiqué qu'on avait jamais été
concerné par directement concerné par
ces ingérences vous les avez qualifiées
d'assez grossière est-ce que vous
pourriez revenir sur votre expérience ou
votre analyse de ces tentatives
d'ingérence russe en France pour que
nous puissions avoir une meilleure
appréciation de la manière dont vous les
voyez que son grossière c'est qu'elles
sont tellement visibles que
l'idée que les populations de nos pays
européens soient influençable à ce point
que les comptes je sais pas un grand
spécialiste des réseaux sociaux et donc
mon vocabulaire est peut-être pas
totalement adapté mais enfin c'est quand
fantômes qui sont d'ailleurs utilisés
pas seulement par les Russes enfin assez
massivement par les russes et une
influence réelle sur les scrutins dans
nos pays est une idée que je trouve
assez farfelue voilà
l'idée que la Russie par exemple était à
l'origine du brexit
affirmation qu'on entend assez souvent
me paraît totalement farfelue ça veut
pas dire qu'ils ont pas cherché à
influencer
les votes au moment du brexit peut-être
mais enfin quand on connaît bien la
Grande-Bretagne on sait qu'il y a au
fond du pays une force qui n'a rien à
voir avec les ingérences russes qui
étaient favorables à ce brexit de la
même façon quand on pense que c'est
les Russes qui ont fait lire le
président Trump ce que j'ai entendu y
compris l'américains de très très haut
niveau honnêtement je pense que c'est un
fantasme encore une fois ça veut pas
dire qu'ils ont pas essayé mais ça veut
dire que l'impact de ces opérations là
je parle de de des réseaux sociaux de
des fausses informations je pense que
cet impact n'est pas négligeable mais
qu'il est comment dirais-je marginal par
rapport à l'objectif que
assigner
d'une manière générale la Russie est un
pays qui est assez
comment dirais-je
brutal dans toute sa dans toute sa dans
toute son dans tout son fonctionnement
je me souviens lors de ce voyage de la
commission de la défense en 1986 nous
étions déjà un certain nombre à être
convaincu que il n'y avait pas de
menaces militaire
existentielle pour les Européens venant
du SS pourquoi parce que
l'URSS était un système qui fonctionnait
mal et donc ils avaient beau accumuler
des armes et des soldats et une immense
puissance il y avait toujours quelque
part quelqu'un qui avait oublié de
mettre de l'essence dans le réservoir du
char quand il ne l'avait pas détourné
ou des problèmes d'organisation qui
rendaient cet outil militaire assez non
pas
me faire dire ce que je ne veux pas dire
je dis pas que c'est pas une menace mais
enfin en tout cas pas une menace au
niveau de de
l'existence même de nos de nos pays et
je mets le nucléaire à part je j'ai dans
mes visites
en URSS puis en Russie j'ai remarqué que
les choses se passaient jamais comme
vous le comme vous les enfin comme elles
sont prévues il y a toujours quelqu'un
quelque part qui a pas vraiment fait son
boulot ou qui a oublié d'être là et je
trouve que l'exemple peut-être le plus
triste et le plus
symbolique de ce mauvais fonctionnement
du de la Russie en général c'est
l'accident
de
du président de Total
qui est
typiquement voilà un
employé qui sans doute un peu abusé
de la vodka à qui on confie un matériel
qui n'a jamais conduit et qu'on envoie
dans une partie de l'aéroport qui dans
lequel il est jamais allé et le résultat
c'est la mort de
monsieur de Marjorie
voilà donc la Russie c'est un immense
pays mais d'une assez grande fragilité
en raison de son de ses
dysfonctionnements internes
je vous remercie ma deuxième question ce
serait quand vous étiez Premier ministre
est-ce que vous avez une perception une
analyse peut-être des services ou
d'autres institutions garantes de la
sécurité de notre pays sur une évolution
peut-être du comportement de la Russie
et de ces façons de s'ingérer dans les
autres démocraties en particulier la
France par notamment du fait de conflits
de l'invasion par la Russie de d'une
partie du territoire géorgien d'autres
tensions géopolitiques qui auraient pu
qui ont sont apparus sur entre 2007 et
2012 est-ce que il y a eu une évolution
de votre point de vue du point de vue de
des services que vous avez eu à
connaître et question parallèle
parallèlement cette évolution politique
est-ce qu'il y a une évolution des
relations économiques avec la Russie une
intensification des investissements dans
les contrats énergétiques dans un
certain nombre de domaines de domaines
régaliens ou d'entreprises dans
lesquelles l'État
à Maya parti Renault ou un certain angry
est-ce qu'il y a une évolution à la fois
de l'extérieur des ingérences russes
envers la France et une évolution depuis
la France de la stratégie
d'investissement des relations faites
avec la Russie sur des contrats qu'on
peut qualifier de stratégique
j'ai pas jusqu'où je dois remonter mais
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure mais visite
en URSS
j'aurais pu évoquer ma présence au
dernier conseil du Parti communiste de
l'Union soviétique en tant que
représentant de ma famille politique
j'avais croisé les membres du Parti
communiste français qui était
malheureux de voir disparaître le parti
frère avec lequel ils avaient collaboré
dans une forme d'ingérance qui était à
l'époque totalement assumée par tout le
monde mais
à partir de 1993
j'ai été ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche et nous
avons entrepris de coopérer avec la
Russie sur les sujets de recherche et
sur les sujets de l'espace
à l'époque il faut souvenir que la chute
de l'Union soviétique a entraîné un
véritable chaos
la recherche russe était par terre les
chercheurs n'étaient plus payés les
laboratoires de recherche étaient en
déshérence et nous avons
encouragé les organismes de recherche
français publics à coopérer avec les
organismes de recherche russe en fait
pour l'essentiel pour aider les
chercheurs russes à survivre et en même
temps pour profiter des capacités de la
recherche fondamentale russe notamment
en matière de mathématiques je pense
aussi aux industriels de l'aéronautique
qui ont beaucoup utilisé les immenses
facilités les souffleries que les
cavalu l'Union soviétique qui ne savait
plus à rien et enfin nous avons engagé
une coopération en matière spatiale
j'ai été avec d'autres à l'origine à
cette époque de la création de la
première société franco-rus de
commercialisation de vol de Soyouz de
vol de lancement de satellite la société
starcep qui visait en fait à donner des
garanties
occidentales en termes de
commercialisation de finances
d'assurance etc à des lancements à des
lancements de Soyouz
quand j'ai pris mes fonctions de Premier
ministre puisque entre temps j'ai eu des
fonctions de ministre social qui ne
m'ont pas conduit à une coopération très
fructueuse avec la Russie
la période était très particulière
d'abord parce que comme vous l'avez
rappelé
Vladimir Poutine était premier ministre
dans le cadre d'un swap qu'il avait
réalisé avec le président Medvedev pour
tordre un peu l'esprit de la
Constitution russe et donc c'était mon
interlocuteur
et j'ai eu avec Vladimir Poutine pendant
ces cinq années une relation assez
intense et qui a été très fructueuse
pour l'économie française et je vais
vous en citer quelques exemples parce
que je pense qu'à cette époque
la Russie et le président Poutine avait
un objectif qui était un objectif de
modernisation du pays qui n'était pas
encore dans la phase que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui
il y a eu d'ailleurs des discussions à
cette époque je vous le rappelle pour
créer une forme de zone de libre-échange
entre la Russie et l'Union européenne
qui avait été proposée par le président
Sarkozy qui avait pas fait l'unanimité
chez les Européens mais en ce qui
concerne la relation franco-rus c'est
une période où
Renault est devenu le premier
constructeur automobile en Russie
d'ailleurs tous les exemples que je vais
vous citer sont des exemples qui sont
favorables à la France c'est-à-dire
c'est des exemples c'est pas des
exemples qui nous mettent en dépendance
de la Russie c'est exactement le
contraire donc Renaud a racheté aftovas
qui était un grand entreprises russes et
devenue le premier constructeur
automobile en Russie
Alstom a investi dans les chemins de fer
russe
la Société Générale est devenue
quasiment la première banque étrangère
en Russie
Vinci a construit l'autoroute entre
Saint-Pétersbourg et Moscou
total est devenu le
la tributaire d'un des plus grands
champs gaziers Yamal au nord de la
Russie
Soyouz a été installé on a construit un
pas de tir à courroux pour lancer ce use
à partir de Kourou pour pouvoir
diversifier
compléter l'offre de lancement
européenne
je cherche si j'en oublie encore mais il
me semble que j'en oublie donc ça a été
une période assez
assez
riche en matière de coopération
économique et je voudrais insister sur
un point c'est que
pendant cette période il était assez
facile de parler avec la Russie et c'est
parce que il était assez facile de
parler avec la Russie que le président
Sarkozy a pu stopper l'opération
militaire en Géorgie car je rappelle que
au mois d'août
je crois
la Russie était entrée en conflit avec
la Géorgie que le président Sarkozy qui
était Président de l'Union européenne en
exercice s'est rendu
à Moscou et après une discussion qui a
été assez orageuse a obtenu l'arrêt des
combats et le retrait des forces des
forces russes
moi c'est mon expérience après 2012 je
ne suis plus en charge des affaires de
notre pays et donc je ne peux pas
m'exprimer sur ce qui s'est passé après
en tout cas en ce qui concerne la
coopération économique
merci Monsieur le prémisse vous avez
mentionné une intensification fructueuse
des des échanges économiques et des
investissements français en Russie
la Russie et vous le savez est aussi un
régime au niveau de corruption notamment
dans les hauts niveaux ce qu'on appelle
les oligarques évidemment mais suite
justement aussi à l'effondrement de
l'URSS le niveau de corruption du régime
russe est important il allait pas sur
une pente il n'allait pas en
s'améliorant est-ce que compte tenu du
fait que vous intensifiez vous soutenez
l'intensification des relations avec la
réussite que parallèlement vous avez
renforcé aussi la lutte contre les
risques de corruption que pouvait être
liés à ces contrats et les risques
évidemment d'ingérence ou d'influence
qu'il peut y avoir entre deux pays qui
intensifient leur leurs investissements
c'est à dire qu'on peut imaginer que la
réussite aurait pu intensifier ses
efforts pour avoir des relais en France
ou favoriser dans l'autre sens qui était
lié à ces grands contrats avec des
risques avec des risques de corruption
et donc est-ce que les outils de
corruption anti-corruption pardon
française ont été renforcés sur la même
période alors les outils de corruption
française ils ont été renforcés à
plusieurs reprises mais je voudrais
indiquer que le niveau de corruption en
Russie il est pas différent de celui qui
existe en Chine qui existe en Arabie
Saoudite qui existe dans la plupart des
démocrates des pays autoritaires
et donc il est même peut-être à cette
époque là peut-être un peu moins parce
que la caricature qui est faite en
permanence des oligarques il y a au fond
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un oligarque
c'est une bonne question est-ce que
c'est pas si on prend les grands chefs
des grands capitaines d'industrie
française on les appelle des oligarques
pour quelles raisons parce qu'ils sont
riches parce qu'ils sont proches du
pouvoir la définition d'un regard que
c'était en fait des gens qui s'étaient
enrichis au moment de la chute de
l'Union soviétique en s'emparant de
richesse et en les en les caps de
richesse publique et on les captant à
leur à leur profit et donc tous les
responsables d'entreprises en Russie ne
sont pas
coupables de ce crime là certains oui
d'autres non
les contrats qui ont été signés ils ont
été signés dans le respect des règles
françaises et des règles russes on a eu
parfois des discussions un peu
difficiles avec
le gouvernement russe et avec le
président Poutine sur un certain nombre
de sujets
je n'ai pas le souvenir d'une seule
négociation que nous ayons perdue
peut-être que je me trompe mais j'ai
cherché en venant avant de venir dans
cette commission je me souviens pas
d'une négociation très très difficile
sur le président Poutine on a aidé la
Russie oui j'ai oublié cet aspect à
construire un avion de transport qui
s'appelle le Superjet 100 qui a un avion
une sorte de petit Airbus et qui a été
construit en coopération avec Thalès et
sa France ça fera fourni les moteurs et
à l'aise la vionique et le président
Poutine une fois que cet avion a été
construit voulait qu'on l'achète donc je
me souviens d'une discussion de trois
heures extrêmement difficile
où il menaçait de retirer des droits de
vol
au-dessus de la Sibérie je pense que
c'était plus il voulait interdire la 380
survol de la 380 de la Sibérie par la
380 que je pousse de ce genre la
discussion a duré trois heures
il y avait tout le gouvernement français
tout le gouvernement russe qui attendait
pour déjeuner ils étaient debout devant
leur chaise on est arrivé à 4 heures
d'après-midi mais à la fin on n'a pas
acheté le Superjet 100 et le 380
survenait la Sibérie ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que
au moins dans cette période la
négociation avec la Russie était parfois
difficile mais elle était possible
merci Cyprien ma dernière question avant
de donner la parole passer la parole à
Madame la rapporteur vous n'avez pas
souhaité sauf erreur de ma part dans
votre intervention préliminaire revenir
sur le fait que vous ayez occupé jusqu'à
l'agression de l'Ukraine par la Russie
l'agression militaire l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie revenir sur les
deux postes que vous occupiez est-ce que
vous pourriez revenir sur ces deux
postes qu'est-ce qui vous a ce qui
intéresse il me semble cette commission
en tout cas pour ma part c'est comment
vous en tant qu' ancien Premier ministre
quel parcours vous amène à occuper ces
deux postes à quel moment vous estimez
que l'occupation de ces postes sur au
moins une entreprise qui est vraiment
très stratégique celle qui relève des
hydrocarbures ne ne pose pas de de
conflits de loyauté et aussi le magazine
challenge a révélé il me semble la
semaine dernière que vous avez travaillé
pour la société CIFAL dans
une concession une concession pétrolière
et vous auriez été recrutés
à hauteur de 45000 euros pour favoriser
les contacts entre responsables
congolais pardon et des responsables
russes pour l'exploitation de cette
concession pétrolière est-ce que vous
pourriez aussi revenir sur cette
révélation de challenge je n'ai pas
évoqué ces sujets parce que j'imaginais
bien que vous alliez m'interroger dessus
d'abord je voudrais revenir sur les
conditions dans lesquelles j'ai commencé
à partir de 2017 enfin
en 2017 dans les circonstances que
chacun connaît j'ai quitté la vie
publique et de manière définitive
et donc j'ai entamé une carrière
professionnelle
je tiens d'ailleurs à préciser que cette
carrière professionnelle ne regarde que
moi que je n'ai de compte à rendre à
personne sur la manière dont je la
conduis dans le respect naturellement
des lois de la République et des
intérêts et des règlements européens je
suis une personne privée depuis 2017
j'ai commencé par pendant trois ans être
associé d'un d'une société de
d'investissement française
et pendant ces trois années je n'ai
aucune
occasion de travailler avec la Russie
puisque comme vous le savez
travailler avec la Russie pour un
établissement financier européen c'est
s'exposer immédiatement aux sanctions
américaines d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est une période où j'ai siégé au
conseil d'administration d'une
entreprise de
d'intelligence artificielle aux
États-Unis
pour cette entreprise
de
d'investissement françaises j'ai
notamment
ouvert un bureau au Japon j'ai
été à l'origine de la création d'un fond
dédié à la transition énergétique donc
d'un fond qui aujourd'hui doit
représenter près de 2 milliards d'actifs
sous gestion et qui donc est destiné à
tout ce qui touche à la transition
énergétique j'ai créé pour cette société
un conseil international dans lequel
j'ai recruté
un ancien Premier ministre
social-démocrate italiens ou encore
une femme qui est aujourd'hui la
patronne des services de renseignement
américain celle qui coiffent l'ensemble
des services de renseignement américain
donner une idée des activités qui ont
été les miennes pendant ces trois années
au bout de trois ans j'ai décidé de
conduire ma propre activité de conseil
et j'ai commencé à conseiller les
entreprises françaises et des
entreprises européennes et un certain
nombre de ces entreprises m'ont demandé
de les aider à entrer ou à se développer
en Russie sachant que naturellement
j'avais et une connaissance de la Russie
et une connaissance de son
fonctionnement et donc j'ai commencé à
faire des séjours relativement long
enfin en tout cas de quelques semaines
pour aider ces entreprises à se
développer et l'une d'entre elles c'est
l'entreprise CIFAL m'a demandé de
l'aider à établir des contacts avec une
entreprise qui est l'entreprise rosnyff
pour un de ses clients
je veux mentionner à ce sujet d'ailleurs
que les articles qui sont parus sur ce
sujet sont des exemples
j'allais dire de manipulation
soft de l'information puisque je suis
pas concerné par les enquêtes qui sont
en cours
il y a j'ai travaillé pour une
entreprise qui elle est concernée par
une enquête et ça devient en titre
François Fillon concerné par une enquête
sur non je suis pas concerné par cette
enquête
et j'en dirai pas plus sur ce sujet sur
CIFAL puisque il y a une instruction
judiciaire en cours je veux juste faire
une remarque si vous me le permettez
pour dire mon très grand respect pour
siphales et mon très grand respect pour
son dirigeant qui s'appelle Gilles Rémy
sifal c'est une entreprise qui a été
créée au lendemain de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale par les communistes pour
permettre de développer la relation
économique entre la France et la Russie
c'est 15-20 dernières années sont
dirigeants jérémy a
œuvré pour le développement des
entreprises françaises et des intérêts
français en Russie de manière
remarquable et donc aujourd'hui jetez
l'opprobre sur CIFAL parce qu'il y a la
guerre en Ukraine
je trouve que c'est très injuste c'est
pas Gilles Rémy qui a déclenché la
guerre en Ukraine c'est le président
Poutine et Jérémy n'est pas responsable
de la situation
stratégique qui est celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
alors j'en viens maintenant au conseil
d'administration où j'ai accepté de sier
dans le cadre donc des
fonction que j'ai
occupé des missions que j'ai conduites
en Russie pour le compte d'entreprise
française d'un grand nombre enfin d'un
grand nombre d'un nombre important
d'entreprises françaises j'ai été amené
à plusieurs reprises à rencontrer le
président de Zaho Genève qui est une
entreprise pétrolière qui n'intervient
qu'en dehors de la réussite d'une
entreprise qui
pour l'essentiel
gère des
forages et des de l'exploitation de
pétrole et de gaz en Asie pour
l'essentiel en Asie beaucoup au Vietnam
un peu en Amérique latine et un peu en
Asie centrale
j'ai rencontré le président de cette
société à plusieurs reprises pour lui
demander
lui proposer des coopérations avec des
entreprises françaises et notamment
cette entreprise civale ça n'a jamais
abouti mais à la suite de ces
discussions il m'a proposé d'entrer au
Conseil de zarobies Genève et j'ai
considéré que c'était
utile au développement de mes activités
professionnelles en Russie puisqu'on
font mon projet c'était de continuer à
développer
ses activités de conseils des
entreprises françaises et européennes en
Russie et donc j'ai accepté et j'ai
accepté d'autant plus facilement que il
n'y a strictement aucune friction entre
zarobie et Genève et la France c'est une
entreprise qui n'intervient pas en
France qui n'a pas de rapport avec la
France et avec les entreprises
pétrolières françaises puisque comme je
vous l'indiquais elle
œuvre pour l'essentiel en Asie et un peu
en Amérique latine
dans la foulée de cette nomination au
Conseil de zarobi Genève j'ai été
sollicité par le président de Novatech
qui est la société pétrolière qui est
associée avec total dans la gestion de
notamment des gisements gaziers de Yamal
pour siéger au conseil d'administration
d'une société de pétrochimie privée qui
s'appelle Ciboure et donc j'ai accepté
de sierger au conseil d'administration
de cette société où j'étais en charge ça
fera sourire certains mais c'est comme
ça de j'allais dire d'une certaine
occidentalisation de l'entreprise
c'est-à-dire de l'introduction de
critères
environnementaux sociaux et de
gouvernance dans la gestion de Ciboure
je vais pas pouvoir vous en dire
beaucoup plus là dessus pour une raison
très simple c'est que tout ça s'est
passé à la fin de l'année 2021
j'ai assisté à un conseil de la Société
zaroubier Genève j'ai assisté à un
conseil en visioconférence pour cause de
covid de la société Ciboure et j'ai des
l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie donner ma
démission de ces deux conseils
d'administration
je vous remercie madame le rapporteur
vous avez la parole
monsieur le premier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre je voulais dans un
premier temps vous demander si dans le
cadre des différents mandats et
fonctions imminentes que vous avez
exercées notamment
en tant que premier ministrement de la
République vous avez eu l'occasion de
bénéficier d'une sensibilisation de la
part de nos services sur les risques
d'influence
d'incidents d'ingérence étrangère
bien sûr mais concernant un très grand
nombre de pays par exemple
je n'emmène jamais mon téléphone
portable ni mon ordinateur lorsque je me
rends Chine voilà donc évidemment ce
sont des précautions
indispensables et qui va malheureusement
pour un très grand nombre de pays et
j'ai envie de dire un nombre de plus en
plus important de pays dans le monde
merci vous nous avez
donné des informations sur les modalités
et circonstances avec lesquelles vous
aviez été amené en 2021 a rejoint les
conseils d'administration de deux
entreprises du secteur
pétrochimique et
pétrolier de manière générale
à la suite de rencontres et de mise en
contact diverses
est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas que votre qualité
d'ancien Premier ministre de la France
a joué plus qu'un rôle déterminant dans
le recrutement qui a été fait ainsi de
la part de ces deux sociétés dont une et
détenue à 100% par l'État russe
j'imagine que vous aurez à coeur de
poser cette question à beaucoup de
responsable de très haut responsables
pour certains que vous connaissez bien
je évidemment que c'est mon expérience
d'anciens Premier ministre et d'ancien
ministre qui est
souhaitée quand je siège dans un conseil
d'administration en Russie ou quand je
siège dans une société d'investissement
en France
et d'ailleurs
je pense que ce serait quand même utile
que on accepte de reconnaître que le
fait d'avoir été pendant cinq ans chef
du gouvernement vous donne une certaine
expérience et pas seulement un carnet
d'adresses comme je l'entends écrit si
souvent
quand on a exercé des fonctions de
responsabilité
politique d'abord de gestion de grandes
collectivités locales puis ensuite le
gouvernement on a un savoir-faire une
expérience une capacité à gérer des
situations difficiles qui est
naturellement souhaité par des
entreprises et à partir du moment où
j'ai quitté la vie publique je veux le
rappeler je veux dire je suis une
personne privée et je mène ma carrière
professionnelle comme je l'entends si
j'ai envie de vendre des rillettes sur
la place sur la Place Rouge vendrai des
rillettes sur la Place Rouge je le dis
parce que
cette idée que parce que j'ai été
premier ministre je n'ai plus le droit
de d'avoir quelques activités
professionnelles que ce soit ce qui est
pas du tout ce que vous avez dit mais
c'est ce que pense un certain nombre
d'observateurs
ça n'est pas pour moi pour moi pour moi
acceptable la question que vous avez
que vous êtes fondé à me poser c'est la
question de savoir si c'est un cas
d'ingérence étrangère ou pas et moi je
vous réponds non je vous réponds non
pour trois raisons
la première raison c'est que c'est moi
qui suis allé en Russie pour développer
mes activités professionnelles en Russie
avant la déclaration de la guerre et
donc c'est pas les Russes qui sont venus
me chercher la deuxième raison c'est que
les entreprises où j'ai accepté dans
lesquelles j'ai accepté de sierger sont
des entreprises pour lesquelles il n'y a
pas de relation stratégiques avec la
France aucune Ciboure vend un peu de
matériaux qui servent à faire les pneus
de vos voitures et quand ça roule bien
et quant à Genève il y en a pas du tout
et la troisième raison mais là il faudra
me croire sur parole c'est que mon
parcours
montre que je ne suis pas sensible aux
ingérences étrangères et donc et mes
convictions sur la nécessité d'une
relation
réaliste entre la France et la Russie ne
date pas de l'époque où j'ai siégé dans
des conseils d'administration elle a
commencé en 1986 à l'époque où la Russie
s'appelait l'URSS et donc personne ne
peut espérer me faire changer d'avis
d'une manière ou d'une autre à cette
occasion et donc je considère qu'il n'y
a là aucune ingérence étrangère
merci
vous avez vous-même abordé le sujet
certes délicat et sur lequel beaucoup de
gens ont plein d'avis de des pistes de
reconversion professionnelle et
d'évolution de parcours professionnel
pour d'anciens aux responsables
politiques une fois quitté leur fonction
politique et une fois qu'il redeviennent
des personnes privées
il y a des règles et des législations
qui peuvent être ailleurs différentes
d'un pays européen à l'autre dans le cas
de notre pays pensez-vous que le délai
de trois ans durant lequel ancien
au fonctionnaire ou un ancien
responsable politique doit faire valider
sa reconversion par une instance
déontologique et adaptée
il me semble que c'est adapté et en ce
qui concerne c'est beaucoup plus que 3
ans puisque j'ai quitté mes fonctions
exécutives en 2012 donc la question
c'est pas de délais de cet ordre
je je pense qu'il serait tout à fait
dommageable
de cantonner les responsables politiques
et les responsables d'administration
dont le secteur public jusqu'à la fin de
leur jours je pense que c'est pas sain
ça permet pas une bonne respiration de
la vie politique on entend trop souvent
dire que
c'est toujours les mêmes il n'y a pas de
renouvellement et bien je pense que
l'interaction entre le secteur privé le
secteur public qui est d'ailleurs la
caractéristique par exemple de la
politique américaine ne me choque ne me
choque pas
et dernière question mais qui vient en
réalité en complément de ce que nous
venons d'aborder que pensez-vous de
l'idée selon laquelle pourrait être
listé à sombre de catégorie de secteurs
économiques voire de zones géographiques
ou de pays avec lesquels ils pourraient
y avoir
de la part d'anciens aux fonctionnaires
ou d'anciens responsables politiques
une impossibilité de poursuivre ou
d'entamer un parcours professionnel un
parcours de reconversion
je suis totalement hostile
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
du rétrécissement progressif des
libertés individuelles auxquelles on
assiste avec à chaque fois de bons
raisonnements des raisonnements qui sont
enfin les
ou bien on est en conflit avec un état
on a on a plus de relation diplomatiques
avec lui c'est un pays
dangereux et à ce moment-là
naturellement
on ne peut pas y travailler ou bien on a
des relations diplomatiques et et je ne
vois pas de quel droit un état peut
interdire assez ressortissants de
travailler avec des États qui ne sont
pas dans la avec lesquels on n'est pas
en conflit aujourd'hui la situation est
différente puisque on est en conflit
avec la Russie d'ailleurs
il y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire
sur ce conflit et vous savez que j'ai
une opinion qui est pas forcément tout à
fait la même que celle qu'on entend à
longueur d'émission de
sur les télévisions d'information mais
je ne m'exprime pas sur ce sujet et je
ne m'exprimerai pas sur ce sujet parce
que je considère que mon pays est en
conflit avec la Russie
à tort ou à raison il est en conflit
avec la Russie et et ce qui compte pour
moi dans cette dans ces conditions là
c'est l'intérêt de mon pays et donc je
ne ferai rien qui puisse gêner le
gouvernement de mon pays
dans la gestion dans la gestion de ce
conflit c'est ça la règle qu'on doit
s'appliquer et pas
qu'une bureaucratie européenne ou
française se mettent à découper
les régions ou les uns ou les autres
peuvent travailler d'autant que il y a
comme vous le savez une immense
hypocrisie dans cette dans ces analyses
puisque
la manière dont on traite les pays quel
que soit le régime n'est pas du tout la
même par exemple
comme la Chine est loin
personne ne considère que la Chine est
un problème or le régime chinois est
bien plus dur non enfin ça commence un
peu depuis que les depuis 2 ans et
surtout parce que les Américains sont en
train de se rendre compte que ils vont
perdre le leadership mondial donc il y a
une vraie compétition qui s'installe et
un risque de conflit majeur d'ailleurs
qu'à mon avis le seul vrai risque de de
conflits mondial
mais enfin jusqu'à maintenant il n'y
avait pas la même sensibilité en Europe
et en particulier dans les médias
européens par rapport à la Russie et par
rapport à la Chine le régime chinois est
un régime qui est plus dur que le régime
que le régime russe et le régime et la
Chine et de mon point de vue
et en disant ça je sais pas une attaque
contre la Chine c'est juste une
constatation c'est une menace pour notre
économie mondiale et pour notre
influence dans le monde bien plus grande
que la menace la menace russe qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec les pays du Golfe
ce sont des régimes démocratiques
l'Arabie Saoudite est un régime
démocratique
l'Algérie est un régime démocratique
enfin on peut continuer la liste et donc
voilà attention à la manière dont on
dont on cherche à encadrer les activités
privées professionnelles des uns et des
autres la règle pour moi ça doit être la
règle
de la nature de la relation diplomatique
avec le pays
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
parole est à vice-président Dumont
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre merci de vous présenter
ici devant nous pour répondre à nos
questions
c'est extrêmement intéressant d'avoir le
point de vue de quelqu'un qui a été aux
affaires pendant 5 ans sur ce phénomène
des ingérences et j'aimerais en cela
savoir ou pour vous se situe la
frontière entre influence et ingérence
ou est-ce que vous pouvez la définir
est-ce que vous pouvez votre point de
vue d'ancien Premier ministre nous dire
où vous la situez et si à votre avis la
France évidemment en particulier lors de
passage à Matignon a pu franchir cette
frontière à certains moments en
s'immiscant dans la vie et les affaires
de pays étrangers
deuxième question est-ce que ça vous est
arrivé lors de votre passage à Matignon
de déconseiller à des membres de votre
exécutif de se rendre dans telle ou tel
pays pour des risques potentiels
d'ingérence qui était identifié par par
vos services ou avez-vous pu des
conseillers à des parlementaires ou des
ministres qu'ils soient en fonction en
ce moment ou non de travailler à l'issue
de leur mandat ou parce qu'ils ont déjà
terminé leur mandat à ce moment-là avec
des tel ou telle entreprise étrangères
du fait des risques que cela pouvait
comporter qui avait été une fois plus
identifié par vos services en réalité
quels sont qu'elles étaient les mesures
qui ont été prises ont pu être prises
par votre gouvernement par vos services
pour éviter les ingérences étrangères je
vous remercie
frangin il y en a toujours eu il y en
aura toujours on en a nous-mêmes
pratiqués la question c'est au fond de
les
identifier et d'être capable de les
combattre
ce qui pour moi est la frontière c'est
quand un pays par exemple appel à voter
pour un candidat à une élection
présidentielle
ou quand un pays veut
plus possible aujourd'hui
dans notre pays en raison des règles
enfin c'est possible encore dans
d'autres pays dans le monde financés la
vie politique
le reste je dirais qui est des
télévisions qui défendent le point de
vue de la Russie du Qatar ou de je ne
sais qui dans
il faut juste savoir et faire confiance
à la capacité de jugement de nos
concitoyens et à la et à la et à la
pluralité de l'information dans un pays
comme une autre donc là la ligne qui
doit pas être franchie c'est celle qui
consiste à s'ingérer directement dans la
vie politique par des consignes de vote
par des par le choix de candidat ou par
le financement
de cette vie politique est-ce que j'ai
été amené à
dire à des ministres de passerons dans
certains pays
je cherche dans ma mémoire mais je ne
crois pas nous avons eu avec le
président Sarkozy une grande
interrogation
après l'affaire de la Géorgie donc en
août
2008 je crois
nous avions
programmer vous savez qu'il y a
il y a une instance qu'on appelle la
commission la commission
qui en fait la réunion des deux
gouvernements et les deux gouvernements
presque au complet après tout à fait au
complet mais se réunissent de façon
assez régulière je crois que c'était une
fois tous les six mois une fois en
Russie une fois en France il y a ça avec
d'autres pays et ça existe depuis très
longtemps
cette commission franco-rueuses devait
se tenir à Sotchi début septembre et on
a très longtemps hésité avant de la
maintenir compte tenu de ce qui venait
de se passer en Géorgie on a finalement
décidé de la maintenir dans des
conditions
j'allais dire de de distance qui me
permet d'ailleurs d'évoquer un sujet
parce que j'entends souvent dire que
j'ai des relations personnelles avec le
président Poutine
j'ai eu des relations intenses
professionnelles avec le président
Poutine pas de relation personnelle
je n'ai jamais participé à quelques
manifestations privées que ce soit parce
que ça pour moi c'est une ligne qui ne
doit pas être franchie en tout cas tant
qu'on est un responsable un responsable
un responsable politique
ce que j'ai des souvenirs de d'ingérence
française d'avoir si j'en avais je
voulais je voulais je voulais dire pas
il nous est quand même arrivé dans
certains pays africains de se mêler un
peu de ce qui nous regardait pas
au Liban parfois aussi un peu
et dire que ça continue
avec un succès qui est pas fantastique
mais
voilà les anglais sont des grands
spécialistes de la gérance étrangère les
Anglais ont une diplomatie remarquable
et une capacité à agir à travers le
monde où ils avaient en tout cas une
capacité à agir derrière le monde
considérable
les Américains aussi alors je sais bien
que quand il s'agit d'allier c'est pas
le même sujet que quand il s'agit
d'adversaire mais si je peux raconter
une anecdote lorsque j'ai créé ce
conseil international pour la société
d'investissement tickets au capital où
j'avais donc recruté celle qui est
aujourd'hui la patronne des services de
renseignements américains avril Hans un
jour nous avions une discussion sur la
question de savoir si on devait investir
si on pouvait investir dans chez Huawei
chinois Huawei
c'est un certain nombre d'autres
personnes autour de du Conseil se sont
mis à pousser des cris d'or frères en
disant on peut pas investir chez des
gens qui nous écoutent
et donc là je me suis permis de dire que
la NSA m'avait écouté pendant 5 ans
alors vous allez me dire c'est pas les
objectifs sont pas les mêmes c'est vrai
effectivement mais enfin quand même il y
a un sujet
mérite que votre commission puisqu'elle
se travaille sur les ingérences
étrangères
fasse une analyse globale
merci monsieur le Premier
passe la parole à Monsieur bayou
question
ce que je l'ai fait en séquence ou
vous les faites ce qui vous semble le
plus adapté pour obtenir la réponse qui
vous satisfa satisfaire raconte merci
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre de
participer à cette audition
je voulais revenir d'abord sur vos
propos vous dites j'ai pas été concerné
directement par une ingérence russe et
je comprends votre point de vue
comprenez le mien est-ce que vous
estimez pas que par le fait de que
l'ancien Premier ministre soit recruté
par des conseils d'administration
d'entreprise russe proche du pouvoir en
tout cas décrites comme tel est-ce que
c'est pas vous faire le bras finalement
de l'ingérence quand on se met au
service des intérêts financiers russes
proches de l'État russe je sais que vous
faites la distingo sur la question
diplomatique mais
[Musique]
si
ce n'est pas pour votre carnet
d'adresses et votre expérience acquise
lors de votre mandat de Première
ministre alors finalement pourquoi vous
ont-ils recruté et est-ce que c'est par
vraiment trop simple pour le coup de
dire je suis une personne privée je
précise que si j'avais devant moi
Dominique de Villepin également ancien
Premier ministre également aussi avocat
et qui a ensuite
basculé sa société en société de lobby
internationale je lui dirai la même
chose est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que
contrairement à
des fonctionnaires de haut niveau mais
évidemment
moins moins expérimenté on va dire qu'un
ancien Premier ministre il y a une
responsabilité supérieure ne serait-ce
que parce que vous avez connaissance de
secret vous en avez évoqué quelques-uns
je vous en demande pas plus mais de
secret que je ne vous demande pas ici
ils ne sont doucement pas demandé mais
sous couvert de du secret professionnel
et notamment de l'avocat et bien vous
pouvez en faire bénéficier des
entreprises voilà pour une première
question est-ce que le fait de
travailler tout simplement pour une
puissance économique étrangère ne relève
pas de l'ingérence sur Nouveau
c'est pas du tout mon avis
je suis pas avocat d'ailleurs donc je
suis pas protégé par le secret
professionnel
les entreprises dans lesquelles j'ai
j'aurais exercé des fonctions puisque je
les ai pas exercés
étaient des entreprises qui
je vous l'ai dit n'avait aucun intérêt
stratégique
en compétition avec la France
et j'ai dit tout à l'heure que
naturellement les entreprises qu'elles
soient russes ou qu'elles soient
américaines parce que j'ai aussi siéger
dans des conseils américains
s'intéresse à vous parce que vous avez
cette expérience là bien entendu j'ai
pas dit le contraire c'est parce que
vous avez une expérience globale une
vision du monde une capacité à en
comprendre le fonctionnement une analyse
des situations des situations
économiques et tant que la relation
entre la France et la Russie était une
relation normale je ne vois pas
d'obstacles de mon point de vue à
participer à ces conseils
que vous aviez créé en juin 2012 de F
conseil donc c'était effectivement pas
avocat mais conseil je me souviens vous
l'aviez créé 10 jours avant que ce soit
plus possible en fait puisque vous
l'aviez créé juste avant de devenir
député et ensuite c'était incompatible
et je me souviens que en 2016 alors que
vous étiez candidat à la présidentielle
nous n'avions en tant que vos opposants
mais même en tant que citoyen lambda pas
la possibilité de savoir qui était vos
clients et du fait de savoir qui
financer directement ou indirectement
votre campagne en tout cas votre train
de vie
[Musique]
et pour qui vous aviez travaillé et
peut-être à qui deviez-vous
peut-être pas les gens le mot est un peu
fort mais en tout cas reconnaissance et
le fait d'avoir exercé votre travail
moi j'y voyais un problème de
transparence démocratique
les différents candidats on savait
qu'ils étaient d'où venaient leurs
moyens mais pas vous
et avec le recul j'y vois aussi une
question de souveraineté de la France et
d'indépendance
on n'a pas eu du tout le détail de ces
clients ni même de ses activités et tout
ce qui a pu
ressortir de la presse c'était que
c'était le produit de conférence donc
j'ai une question quels étaient les
activités de votre société qui
aujourd'hui dissout et qui est peut-être
moins protégé par ce secret des affaires
en tout cas vous vous en êtes délié
et est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner
le nom de ses clients pendant ces 5 ans
deux choses d'abord pas tout mélanger
aucune de ces activités d'un financé mes
campagnes les campagnes sont financées
selon des règles extrêmement strictes
mais compte de campagne ont été validées
il y a pas un euro qui ait été de mécan
de mon de mes comptes de campagne qui
était financés par mes activités
professionnelles
deuxième réponse
je pensais que vous étiez un observateur
plus attentif de la presse parce que
franchement la quasi-totalité de la
liste de mes clients et m'a été jeté en
pâture un très grand nombre de fois et
d'ailleurs il y a même eu une
instruction judiciaire c'est pour ça que
je vais être assez bref sur le sujet en
2017 le juge d'instruction a inclus dans
l'instruction judiciaire me concernant
toutes mes activités professionnelles
et donc l'ensemble de mes contrats de
mes clients de mes comptes on fait
l'objet de l'analyse de ce juge
d'instruction comme chacun sait est
assez précis dans sa manière de conduire
les instructions et aucun de ces sujets
n'a été retenu à charge contre moi c'est
à dire que sur toutes les questions
liées à mon activité professionnelle
j'ai obtenu un non-lieu ce qui fait que
c'est une chose jugée et que donc je
n'ai pas de de commentaire de
commentaires à faire
pour être
pour ne pas complètement comment
dirais-je
vous décevoir les clients c'était AXA
c'était comment
la société de la Charrière c'était
j'avais une activité avec totale enfin
il y avait il y avait un certain nombre
de groupes français importants pour
lequel j'avais conduit des missions la
banque
banque française une banque d'affaires
françaises importante qui a racheté une
banque en Allemagne
voilà ça me reviendra que j'avais aidé
par exemple auprès des autorités
allemandes pour aider à
plainir un certain nombre d'obstacles
qui avaient dans leur achat de cette
entreprise de cette banque allemande par
une banque française tous ces sujets ont
fait l'objet de l'instruction judiciaire
et non donner lieu à aucune charge
une dernière question qui sur un sujet
différent mais qui intéresse notre
commission on a auditionné l'ancien
l'ambassadeur de France en Russie
Jean-Maurice Ripert qui était
en poste après votre mandat de Premier
ministre je précise il y a pas de
confusion dans les dates
il nous a expliqué que la Russie en tout
cas le Kremlin ou des proches
alors les termes précis c'était que des
membres de partis politiques français
venaient en Russie et repartez ou en
tout cas venaient pour financer leurs
campagnes il a été relativement prudent
lors de cette commission mais il a
néanmoins précisé qu'il parlait de
membres du Front national
est-ce que vous en avez eu vent de fait
que des membres
homme ou femme politique français aller
chercher en Russie alors peut-être du
temps où vous étiez Premier ministre ou
après un financement est-ce que vous en
aviez eu avant et est-ce que vous pensez
que ça c'est une ingérence d'une
puissance étrangère le fait de financer
un parti politique français alors à la
dernière question je réponds oui et je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure je pense que ça
c'est un sujet
d'ingérence en revanche je n'ai aucune
connaissance d'une ingérence de ce type
lorsque j'étais Premier ministre après
je ne sais pas mais
enfin vous vous êtes vous-même engagé
dans la vie politique donc vous avez
vécu des campagnes présidentielles les
règles qui de financement des campagnes
présidentielles sont aujourd'hui d'une
telle tellement stricte que je ne vois
pas comment est-ce que
une puissance étrangère peut financer
une campagne présidentielle je ne vois
pas autrefois oui ça a beaucoup existé
aujourd'hui les règles sont d'une
très grande rigueur et elles sont
examinées par les autorités compétentes
avec une rigueur encore plus grande donc
je veux vraiment je je serai extrêmement
étonné que de l'argent provenant de
l'étranger de manière significative
puisse
aboutir dans les comptes de campagne
d'un candidat
est-ce que vous avez le temps de poser
votre question voilà vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Premier Ministre quelques
simples questions comment caractériser
caract bon comment définiriez-vous les
relations entre les entreprises pour
lesquelles vous étiez russe pour
lesquels vous étiez censé travailler et
le gouvernement russe lui-même
vous avez précisé que vous avez oublié
Genève ne perd pas en France et que de
ce point de vue ça ne vous plaçait pas
dans une situation de conflit d'intérêt
est-ce que d'une façon un peu triviale
vous pourriez nous préciser dans ces
cas-là ce que vous pouviez apporter
hasard en business je fais pas un jour à
vos compétences mais et même à votre
capacité à comprendre le monde mais si
leurs activités sont plutôt en Asie
voilà on peut se demander ce que quelle
est la plus-value et est-ce que vous
pourriez préciser un peu les étapes du
processus de recrutement parce que
l'évocation que vous en avez faites
étaient très affinité j'ai envie de dire
vous avez rencontré le le PDG et puis
les choses se sont faites est-ce que
vous pourriez rentrer un peu plus dans
le détail s'il vous plaît alors d'abord
faut préciser ce que c'est un conseil
d'administration c'est pas une fonction
exécutive
et toutes les entreprises
du monde ont des conseils
d'administration dans lequel il y a des
administrateurs qui siègent en général
trois fois quatre fois cinq fois dans
l'année
ils apportent leur regard leur jugement
ils sont membres des comités
d'auditsenseurs c'est pas c'est pas des
fonctions exécutives donc c'est des
fonctions de contrôle
ou font chacun à partir du moment où il
a une certaine compétence et une
certaine connaissance du fonctionnement
des affaires peut apporter son sa
plus-value deuxième remarque la société
zarubié Genève est une société d'État
c'est incontestable et donc le processus
a été une sollicitation du directeur de
cette entreprise
une discussion autour
de la mission de
comment dirais-je des contraintes du
rythme de réunion etc et ensuite
une nomination par décret puisque en
Russie c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
qu'est-ce que je pouvais apporter à
zarubiage neuf
un regard sur la situation
internationale
vous avez on a évoqué tout à l'heure le
l'Asie j'ai par exemple développer des
activités pour le fond d'investissement
français dont j'étais partenaire en Asie
au Japon à Singapour voilà c'est j'ai
changé de
comment dirais j'ai changé de vie je
fais autre chose aujourd'hui et et je
vais beaucoup en Asie et quant à la
société
Ciboure c'est une société absolument
privée ou comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure on m'avait demandé d'être au
Conseil une sorte de référent sur les
sujets d'environnement de gouvernance et
sur les sujets sociaux je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure je pouvais pas vous en
dire beaucoup plus puisque en fait j'ai
jamais siégé réellement dans ces
entreprises et d'ailleurs je précise un
point c'est que je n'ai jamais touché un
centime
d'argent venu de Russie dans toute ma
vie politique et privé jamais alors vous
allez me dire si j'avais continué à être
membre de ces deux conseils
d'administration j'aurais naturellement
été rémunérés comme tous les membres de
conseils d'administration mais comme
j'ai démissionné dans les conditions que
vous savez ça n'a pas été le cas donc je
n'ai jamais touché un centime d'argent
en provenance de Russie
merci de vos réponses une dernière
question vous avez parlé donc de votre
travail pour une société d'intelligence
artificielle etatsunienne et dans le
même temps vous avez précisé à quel
point les États-Unis vous semblaient à
la rigueur plus ingérrante que n'importe
quel autre puissance
est-ce que vous pourriez nous expliquer
dans quelle mesure finalement ces
sociétés cette société là
ne vous placez pas dans une forme de
conflit d'intérêts plus important dans
la mesure où dans la on comprend que il
s'agit d'un enjeu stratégique
l'intelligence artificielle et que d'une
certaine façon
permettre aux États-Unis de maintenir
leur situation hégémonique dans ce
domaine là ou en tout cas de leur
leadership très fort c'est une forme de
d'aide qui est un peu peut-être curieuse
d'abord j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
l'ingérence américaine à travers le
principe d'extéritorialité
je ne place pas ça sur le même plan que
l'ingérence venait de pays de pays
autoritaires mais je voulais tout à
l'heure dire que c'est quand même un
énorme sujet pour l'économie française
et pour l'économie européenne peut-être
au fond aujourd'hui si vous êtes le
patron d'une grande entreprise
européenne vous vous avez deux
souveraineté à respecter
souveraineté j'allais dire nationale et
européenne et puis vous avez la
souveraineté américaine qui s'impose à
vous en tout état de cause il y a un
livre magnifique sur ce sujet écrit par
un ancien cadre de d'Alstom qui a fait
quelques années de quelques mois de
prison aux États-Unis dans des
conditions
d'un point de vue juridique parfaitement
scandaleuse mais la différence
évidemment par rapport à la Russie c'est
que les entreprises américaines ne sont
pas liées à ce à ce travail d'ingérence
ce sont des entreprises privées
qui ont pas de lien enfin en tout cas
pour un grand nombre d'entre elles qui
ont pas de lien avec avec le
gouvernement américain et l'entreprise
dans laquelle j'ai travaillé siéger
pendant 5 ou 6 ans
faisait un
une forme d'intelligence artificielle
qui était pas très stratégique mais qui
est assez utile qui consiste à mettre de
l'intelligence artificielle dans le dans
la relation téléphonique que vous avez
avec votre avec votre fournisseur voilà
quand vous appelez votre banque vous
appelez votre opérateur téléphonique au
lieu de faire le 1 faire le 2 faire le 3
cette entreprise met de l'intelligence
artificielle dans le système
c'est-à-dire que quand vous appelez
toutes les informations vous concernant
remonte ce qui dans notre pays n'est pas
très très stratégique n'est pas très
important parce qu'il y a des règles
de protection de la vie privée qui sont
très strict mais aux États-Unis c'est
gigantesque par exemple aux États-Unis
on va savoir quel est le niveau de
revenu de l'immeuble dans lequel vous
habitez
à partir de là le système d'intelligence
artificielle essaye de prédire les
questions que vous allez poser et
surtout
d'imaginer les produits que vous
pourriez acheter et là où ça devient
très sophistiqué c'est que
l'intelligence artificielle va choisir
l'opérateur qui va vous répondre parce
que c'est celui qui est le plus à même
de vous voyez que c'est pas très
stratégique quoi
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre
madame clapot s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre fait avoir trois
questions pour vous
première question j'ai sursauté tout à
l'heure mais je pense que vous allez
préciser votre pensée à propos des
oligarques vous êtes un bon connaisseur
de la vie économique russe et la vie
politique russe aussi et donc vous
connaissez les liens étroits qui
existent entre oligarques et pouvoir des
liens qui vont de la connivence à la
haine et qui ont d'ailleurs
entraîné de façon surprenante des décès
des accidents inexpliqués et en tout cas
avant ça des emprisonnement donc j'ai
été un peu surprise tout à l'heure de
vous entendre
minimiser la différence entre les
oligarques russes et les chefs
d'entreprise
occidentaux donc est-ce que vous
pourriez préciser votre pensée s'il vous
plaît
ce que j'ai voulu dire c'est qu'il faut
pas enfin cette généralisation qui fait
que il y a le bien d'un côté le mal de
l'autre il y a cette Russie épouvantable
qu'à tous les défauts de la terre et
puis l'Occident merveilleux et parfait
est une vision qui est évidemment fausse
et qui est évidemment inexact et donc il
y a en Russie un système économique qui
est totalement vertical et dépend de
l'état bien sûr mais c'est le cas en
Arabie Saoudite c'est le cas au Qatar
c'est le cas dans les émirats c'est le
cas en Chine c'est le cas dans en Chine
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais enfin
c'est quand même pas très loin du même
système et ce que j'ai voulu dire tout à
l'heure c'est que traiter tous les chefs
d'entreprise russe de la même façon
penser que parce qu'ils sont chefs
d'entreprise et qu'ils ont réussi c'est
tous des je sais pas des corrompus des
gens
totalement inféodé au pouvoir je trouve
que c'est injuste et ça ne correspond
pas à la réalité il y a des chefs
d'entreprise de qualité en Russie et il
y en a d'autres qui sont enrichis dans
des conditions qui sont des conditions
discutables qui d'ailleurs étaient assez
liées si vous vous en souvenez à la
manière dont
la Russie
était prise en main par toutes les
organismes de conseils anglo-saxons au
moment de la chute de l'Union soviétique
parce que c'est là que ça s'est passé
l'Union soviétique c'était fondé
beaucoup de d'Américains sont arrivés en
Russie pour expliquer aux Russes comment
on faisait fonctionner l'économie
libérale et c'est comme ça qu'on
commençait à s'installer les premiers
oligarques en accaparent des richesses
qui n'ont pas contribué à créer par leur
propre intelligence ou par leur poste de
travail mais aujourd'hui il faut
distinguer
parmi les responsables russes il y en a
qui sont tout à fait dans ce sché il y
en a d'autres qui sont des gens de
qualité et j'ai rencontré notamment dans
l'entreprise Ciboure toute une classe de
dirigeants
de moins de 40 ans beaucoup formé
d'ailleurs dans les pays occidentaux qui
sont des gens tout à fait comparables à
ceux qui gèrent les entreprises
occidentales
c'était ça la nuance que je voulais
apporter mais je ne nie pas du tout que
il y ait un système
vertical dirigé par le pouvoir
voilà dans d'autres pays c'est des
familles si on prend l'Arabie Saoudite
ou le Qatar c'est tous les membres de la
famille royale qui possèdent les
entreprises du pays c'est une autre
façon de concevoir les choses
merci deuxième question
lors de des premières auditions de cette
commission d'enquête nous avons entendu
des experts des universitaires qui ont
nous avons entendu des experts des
universitaires qui ont attiré notre
attention sur les ressorts humains qui
peuvent amener quelqu'un à céder aux
sirènes de la corruption ou des
approches et donc des tentatives
d'ingérence
en particulier ce sont le besoin de
reconnaissance le besoin d'argent ça
nous a été bien expliqué par les experts
alors vous qui avez observez vos
semblables français quand vous étiez aux
affaires et puis vous vous collègues
russes est-ce que vous avez constaté des
tentatives d'ingérence basées sur ces
ressources humains dans les personnes
que vous avez côtoyé
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que je n'avais
pas eu directement connaissance
d'ingérence comme cela on imagine bien
qu'il y a des gens qui peuvent être
tentés par des propositions financières
à l'échange
autrefois du SS il y avait d'autres
méthodes pour attirer les
occidentaux dans les filets du Parti
communiste
et je me souviens que dans la première
mission que j'ai conduit en Union
soviétique nous avions été confrontés à
ce risque-là et oui bien sûr c'est une
réalité mais j'en ai jamais rencontré
qui soit d'une dimension telle que on me
les fait remonter voilà donc c'est pas
pour moi une généralité et je crois
vraiment alors ça c'est vraiment une
conviction profonde que le
comment dirais-je le risque de
corruption en Russie est élevé mais pas
plus que dans les autres pays
avec des régimes équivalents dans le
monde et je trouve que
cette focalisation sur la Russie est
dommageable parce que d'une certaine
façon elle ne nous fait pas voir les
dangers qui sont ailleurs
donc si je retrace la chronologie
invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie le
24 février 2022 et vous démissionnez vos
fonctions le 25 février 2022
avec 14 mois de recul aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous jugez qu'il y avait des signes
avant-coureurs à cette catastrophe
absolue qui aurait pu vous amener à
considérer que la ligne rouge était
franchie plutôt et à démissionné plutôt
je pourrais vous répondre d'une manière
différente en vous disant qu'il y avait
des risques avant-coureurs qui auraient
pu aussi nous conduire à prendre des
mesures pour éviter cette catastrophe
absolue mais comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure que je ne viendrai pas
aujourd'hui gêner l'action du
gouvernement par des jugements sur la
façon dont toute cette affaire a été
gérée je m'abstiendrai je me suis trompé
sur un point je le reconnais bien
volontiers je j'étais convaincu que
le président Poutine ne passerait pas à
l'acte
et la veille de l'invasion j'ai eu une
discussion avec le vice-Premier ministre
en charge de l'énergie puisque j'avais
entrepris notamment avec sifal
d'organiser à Paris une sorte de forum
ou de coloc
réunissant des entreprises russes et
toutes les grandes entreprises
françaises intéressées autour de la
question de l'hydrogène de la production
de l'hydrogène propre etc et
il ressortait de cette discussion
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez du
timing mais l'effort une partie des
forces russes qui étaient massées à la
qui faisait des exercices à la frontière
ukrainienne avait été retirée et tout le
monde avait pensé que c'était le signe
d'une forme de détente et c'est
exactement le climat de l'entretien que
j'avais de la veille de ce de cette
invasion
je pense que oui parce que quand on
réfléchit
à cette décision d'envahir l'Ukraine
elle est terrible elle est terrible pour
tout le monde mais elle est d'abord
terrible pour la Russie et donc c'est
une erreur c'est une faute qui a été
commise par la Russie qui va avoir des
conséquences à très long terme pour elle
pour les graines pour l'Europe
et le président Poutine que je
connaissais puisque en fait moi je l'ai
rencontré de manière intense entre 2007
et 2012 je l'ai revu
dans des manifestations publiques deux
fois entre 2012 et 2017
et je l'ai vu une fois après 2017 en
je participais au Conseil mondial de la
Fédération Internationale de
l'Automobile donc j'étais un des
vice-présidents et là le Conseil Mondial
se tenait à Saint-Pétersbourg et le
président Poutine apprenant que j'étais
à Saint-Pétersbourg a demandé à me voir
donc je suis allé le voir et
en allant vers Moscou je me demandais de
quoi est-ce qu'on allait parler puisque
aucune responsabilité
donc je cherchais
les thèmes de de l'entretien
et j'ai choisi en arrivant à cet
entretien j'ai choisi de lui dire que la
situation d'isolement diplomatique dans
laquelle la Russie s'installer à cause
du conflit au bombasse et de la question
de la criminée était une impasse et
qu'il fallait qu'il l'ouvre le dialogue
diplomatique pour essayer de sortir de
cette impasse et je me souviens toujours
de son sa réponse il m'a regardé avec un
air dubitatif et il m'a dit ah oui et
avec qui je parle
et donc là j'avais pas réfléchi à cette
question suffisamment donc j'ai passé en
revue dans ma tête la totalité des chefs
de gouvernement européen et
j'ai fini par lui dire bah il faut
parler avec le président Macron
et en rentrant de ce voyage j'ai appelé
le président Macron pour lui tenir le
tenir informé de cette de cet échange
et lui indiquer qu'il y avait de mon
point de vue une voix de dialogue avec
la Russie qu'il fallait ouvrir
voilà c'est
c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire à ce
niveau je pense que il y avait des
solutions pour éviter cette crise on a
réussi à stopper la Russie en Géorgie je
pense que c'était possible de le faire
là
peut-être pas au moment où on s'y est
pris c'est-à-dire que le la dégradation
des relations a commencé en 2014 en fait
c'est en 2014 qui aurait fallu sans
doute être plus actif sur le plan
diplomatique
maintenant ça sert pas à grand-chose de
de constater ça parce que la situation
elle est dramatique elle va durer
longtemps et de mon point de vue elle va
se traduire par une fracture
très très importante entre le monde
occidental et une grande partie du reste
du monde
merci madame chassagnol vous avez la
parole
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour votre
présence pour vos réponses
vous avez dit que vous n'avez pas été
témoin d'ingérence directement néanmoins
vous avez été au coeur des liens
diplomatiques politiques entre la France
et la Russie dans votre expérience à la
fois politique et professionnelle est-ce
que cette cette expérience vous a permis
de constater que des partis politiques
ou des élus individuellement avaient des
liens privilégiés avec la Russie avec
ses dirigeants ou avec ses oligarques
voire des liens de nature à impliquer
des ingérences ou une influence sur la
politique nationale ou sur la politique
européenne et si vous en avez eu
connaissance ou si vous avez pu le
supposer
quelle partie politique ou quelle
personne aurait pu être soumis à cette
influence je vous remercie
suivant les époques j'ai écouté tout à
l'heure votre
l'audition de Jean-Pierre Chevènement et
il a eu une remarque très très juste
fait comme si la Russie avait été un
moment un pays quasi démocratique qui
tout d'un coup c'était devenu une
dictature non vous avez réussi à
toujours été
un régime autoritaire et même il y a eu
des époques où c'était pire
qu'aujourd'hui enfin si on peut faire
une échelle dans le dans le
dans ce qui est pire en matière de droit
de l'homme et en matière de de liberté
de liberté publique et donc c'est pas
une découverte il y a pas personne
découvre tout d'un coup que la Russie
est un pays autoritaire et dans
l'histoire de la relation franco-russe
suivant les époques il y a eu des partis
politiques qui ont été plus proche que
d'autres de la Russie à des moments
différents voilà
c'est pas c'est pas un scoop de dire ça
c'est une réalité
est-ce que ça a eu une influence il y a
eu une époque où la Russie
affichée ouvertement sa volonté de
comment dirais-je de propager la
révolution mondiale et où il y avait en
France un parti un parti communiste qui
affichait sa volonté de participer à
cette révolution mondiale donc là il y
avait une un lien qui était extrêmement
fort il y a un très beau livre qui vient
d'être écrit par un ancien inspecteur
des finances et diplomates français sur
les relations entre de Gaulle et la
Russie qui est fascinant de ce point de
vue là
il y a notamment des
exemples dans ce livre parce que il est
lié aux Archives secrètes russes qui ont
été ouvertes assez récemment sur ces
sujets là et il y a des échanges par
exemple qui montrent que quand
la relation entre de Gaulle et les
Américains devenaient compliqué pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale il se servait
de Staline et de la Russie pour
contrebalancer
les vilenies que lui faisaient les
Américains donc c'est voilà donc ça
c'est une réalité qui est
comment dirais-je documenté par par les
historiens
il y a des partis politiques en France
qui ont toujours considéré le mien on
faisait partie je sais pas s'il en fait
encore partie mais n'en faisait partie
qui considérait que nous avions le
devoir d'avoir une relation
spéciale avec la Russie en raison de la
géographie de ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure et avec le président Sarkozy on
a conduit
les affaires de la France avec dans cet
état d'esprit là voilà je peux pas vous
en dire plus
merci à vous avez une deuxième question
monsieur
merci merci monsieur le Président j'ai
Premier ministre
une première question tout d'abord liée
vous avez dit je suis d'accord avec vous
que faut absolument pas qu'on
rentre dans une mentalité qui
empêcherait
les personnes qui ont le talent de le
faire de passer du service du secteur
privé au secteur public et vice-versa je
pense que
ces personnalités peuvent nourrir l'un
et l'autre et tant que les règles sont
respectées notamment de transparence
et que les situations de conflit
d'intérêt sont évitées ce serait c'était
quelque chose de je pense bénéfique d'où
ma première question vous n'étiez plus
en responsabilité quand la Haute
Autorité de transparence de la vie
politique a été créée il me semble en
2013 ou 2014
la question c'est est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu l'occasion de de soumettre une
déclaration sur le patrimoine soit
d'intérêt au titre de des obligations de
transparence de cette autorité et
cette question n'est pas personnelle
simplement j'aimerais avoir votre
opinion
informé puisque maintenant vous êtes
devenu je pense un expert dans la
gestion notamment des fonds
d'investissement vous connaissez très
bien comment sont structurés ces
véhicules avec les bénévolutions
bénéficiaires et ensuite la
structuration des participations est-ce
que vous pensez si vous la connaissez
suffisamment pour pouvoir avoir une
punition sur le sujet que ces
obligations déclaratives auxquelles sont
soumis les autorités publiques les
hommes publics par la chatte PvP est
suffisante et permet effectivement
d'identifier les situations potentielles
de contrôle de conflit d'intérêt
je sais pas où on en est aujourd'hui
je
constate que dans le secteur privé
contrairement à une idée reçue en tout
cas au moins dans le secteur financier
les
contraintes sont très très élevées
et les services de compagnance des
entreprises financières aider d'ailleurs
par
l'automatisation des contrôles dans
lequel l'intelligence artificielle va
venir encore ajouter une couche
sont d'une rigueur extrême
qui parfois d'ailleurs est paralysante
par exemple alors ça c'est je m'éloigne
un tout petit peu du sujet des conflits
d'intérêt mais
les choix
imposés par
ce système aux établissements financiers
qui les amène à ne pas financer
certaines nos activités peuvent virer
parfois l'absurde
j'ai le souvenir d'avoir entendu
un service de complaisance refusé un
investissement dans une entreprise
qui d'une manière ou d'une autre
fabriquer des pièces pour les
sous-marins nucléaires ou motifs que
c'était pas bien d'investir dans la
défense
qu'un établissement financier pouvait
pas investir ce qui était la règle
quasiment jusque à ces événements en
Ukraine depuis la guerre d'Ukraine tout
d'un coup la défense est redevenue alors
je reconnais que je m'éloigne un tout
petit peu du sujet mais c'est pour dire
que là il faut il faut faire attention
moi peut-être que c'est une question de
génération et de mais j'ai la nostalgie
d'une époque où il y a des arbitres
qui sont capables de peser le pour et le
contre dans des situations et de dire là
on y va là on y va pas et pas des
systèmes automatisés
un peu stupide
bureaucratique qui pèse sur les
responsables publics l'exemple que
j'aime bien citer c'est celui autrefois
dans mes débuts de ma vie politique il y
avait des préfets dans les départements
il y en a toujours moi je suis pas sûr
en tout cas ils ont pu tout à fait le
même rôle autrefois le préfet il prenait
des décisions c'est à dire que il y
avait un service administratif qui
n'était pas d'accord avec une décision
il y en avait un autre qui
était favorables il y avait un arbitre
qui a un moment donné était capable de
prendre ses responsabilités et dire on y
va on y va pas aujourd'hui c'est
totalement terminé pourquoi parce que
l'arbitre ne veut pas prendre une
décision qui l'exposerait à des risques
personnels parce que il aurait un moment
donné était limite par rapport à une
réglementation par rapport à un texte
c'est ça le sujet de la de l'autorité de
la transparence c'est c'est comment
faire pour que il y ait une grande
rigueur dans l'examen des conflits
d'intérêt mais que cette rigueur ne
devienne pas stupides et bureaucratiques
et n'aboutissent pas à des résultats
absurdes et puis le deuxième sujet c'est
que les hommes politiques sont la cible
de alors pour des raisons de compétition
mais aussi en raison du climat politique
et social général et donc il y a un
sujet de mise
comme on dirait en pâture de leur
patrimoine de leur
activité qui de mon point de vue peut
parfois être à la limite du malsain
un petit peu éloigné du coup je vais
repréciser un petit peu non non mais
c'est il y a pas de problème
du coup je sais pas si vous connaissez
les dernières mais les derniers
évolutions en fait disent que si par
exemple un député actuellement était
actionnaire de d'un fond par exemple
et bien ce député devrait uniquement
déclarer sa participation dans ce fond
mais pas les actifs sous-jacents à ce
fond et donc pas les entreprises
auxquelles ils participent à travers ce
fond est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
une manière adaptée de faire les choses
et que ça révèle adéquatement les
conflits d'intérêts potentiels c'est à
dire que si le député est obligé de
déclarer la totalité des entreprises qui
sont financées par son fond il y a assez
peu de chance pour que le fond le garde
dans
danser dans ces voilà c'est
est-ce que c'est possible aujourd'hui
pour un député
d'avoir des activités
financières exécutives
je sais pas
il y a toujours eu sur ce sujet
Comment dirige il y avait des tolérances
c'est à dire que autrefois vous pouviez
être avocat
vous pouviez être médecin vous pouviez
en gros vous pouvez avoir une profession
libérale et être parlementaire en
revanche vous pouviez pas avoir
d'activité
professionnelle autre que les
professions libérales ce qui était une
drôle de façon de concevoir les choses
où on interdit tout on interdit rien
enfin je dirais il
y a pas des professions nobles et
d'autres qui ne le sont pas mais je suis
pas sûr que je souhaiterais intéressant
sur le sujet parce que j'ai trop de je
suis trop daté par rapport à
des pratiques qui étaient des pratiques
très différentes
donc
vous êtes trop modeste deuxième question
du coup j'adore j'étais alors j'étais un
peu surpris apparemment de votre
exposition et je l'étais encore plus
après quand je vous ai trouvé très
différent
du fait d'intelligence artificielle et
du coup je suis revenu en arrière je me
suis dit que j'étais encore plus surpris
du coup de votre appréciation de
l'influence potentielle de la
technologie et des réseaux sociaux sur
les résultats d'élection d'élection
importante vous avez il me semble un peu
balayé du revers de la main un peu
rapidement la capacité
de certaines
ingérences extérieures d'avoir influé
notamment on a parlé du brexit de
l'élection de Trump
on se rappelle tous de l'affaire de
Cambridge Analytica avec les suspicions
d'influence de la part de la Russie
aussi bien sur le brexit que sur que sur
l'élection de Trump et
il me semble que vous avez dit bon c'est
pas possible d'influer sur une élection
c'est trop gros en fait il faut il faut
se rappeler que même si bon le brexit
était passé un million de fois près donc
c'est 500 000 personnes qui changent de
vie c'est compliqué par contre Trump
avait gagné son élection en ayant 3
millions de votes de moins que Hillary
Clinton l'élection finalement si vous
rappelez c'était jouer 6 heures du matin
notre heure sur un ou deux petits États
qui se sont joués à 10 ou 15000 après
donc finalement Cambridge Analytica qui
par son design a pour but d'analyser
très précisément les profils
psychologiques profils politiques de
certains électeurs pour déterminer une
sorte de ciblage très précis d'une
action de propagande politique et de
marketing politique à un moment donné ça
peut faire basculer une élection bon
vous n'étiez pas impliqué dans cette
dame ma question c'est elle porte plus
sur l'élection de 2017 dans laquelle
vous étiez très directement impliqué et
moi je me rappelle qu'à l'époque il y
avait eu là encore ça s'appelle des
bottes les robots qui qui aident à
drainer le trafic des réseaux sociaux et
à pousser certaines informations vers
certaines personnes donc on a eu on a
des bottes qui qui sur nos réseaux
sociaux surtout sur Twitter et en France
on avait aussi rechartoudet et Sputnik
était actif depuis 2016 il me semble et
qui en 2000 à la vision des élections
présidentielles de 2017 essaie de
notoriété publique et je pense que ça a
été reconnu assez clairement on surtout
pris une position publique plutôt
anti-incandidat spécifique qui était
anti Macron en diffusant notamment
certaines informations entre guillemets
issues des Macron lixes donc des
informations plutôt apporter à connaître
à connotation négative et péjorative sur
ce candidat tout en étant plutôt discret
quant à leur couverture des autres
candidats favoris notamment de vous-même
de Madame Le Pen et de Monsieur
Mélenchon et on pourrait se demander
d'ailleurs je vous pose la question
si à votre à votre sens est-ce que à
votre corps défendant vous auriez pu
être favorisé par l'interventionnisme
l'influence de la Russie à travers rue
Châteaudun à travers Spoutnik à travers
ses bottes au moment des élections 2017
du volume de
critique s'est abattu sur moi je vois
pas bien où était l'intervention
favorable de qui que ce soit
en faveur de pour enfin celui qui a pris
le plus gros tombeau sur la tête c'est
quand même moi et donc c'est pas
monsieur Macron et donc si j'avais été
le candidat des Russes et que les Russes
avaient été très très influent je pense
que
voilà ça aurait été plus
comment dirais la quantité d'ordures
aurait peut-être été un peu moins élevé
non franchement
vous parlez de de du brexit et de Trump
et vous évoquez un sujet qui est pas le
même qui est le sujet de
les techniques d'intelligence
artificielle au service
des des campagnes électorales etc ça
c'est pas seulement un problème
d'ingérence et en l'occurrence sur
oxfordan étiquette c'est pas les ma
connaissance c'est pas la Russie qui est
derrière cette affaire et surtout ce que
je voulais dire tout à l'heure c'est que
quand vous connaissez la Grande-Bretagne
comme je la connais vous savez qu'il y a
un énorme fond de d'anti
européen historiques et donc
oui bien sûr il peut y avoir une
ingérence étrangère mais vous pouvez pas
dire c'est cette ingérence étrangère là
qui est la cause du brexit c'est ça que
je veux dire parce que c'est voilà comme
chacun sait j'ai épousé une Anglaise et
je me souviens que
dès mes premiers déplacements
chez elle j'avais droit à chaque repas à
la leçon anti-européenne de son père
qui est mort sans jamais changer d'avis
sur le sujet
les Anglais et sur l'élection de Trump
si ce que vous dites est exact
et que
les Américains sont en train de se
prémunir contre ces risques là alors
comment est-ce que Trump peut être aussi
élevé dans les sondages il y a enfin
peut-être que j'ai tort parce que
peut-être que j'ai trop je suis trop
marqué par les campagnes électorales que
j'ai faites avec les instruments qui
étaient ceux de l'époque mais j'ai quand
même du mal à concevoir cette manière
qu'on beaucoup d'observateurs de
considérer en réalité que eux savent
avec le peuple c'est pas
et donc le peuple c'est pas donc il faut
lui expliquer parce que sinon il va se
tromper dans ses choix et et
cette idée que le peuple dépend capable
d'analyser de comprendre de voir les
trucages dans la vie politique je pense
que c'est une erreur moi ma conviction
c'est que en tout cas pour les Français
ils
voient les choses au laser et ils savent
exactement qui sont les candidats quels
sont leurs qualités quels sont leurs
défauts et ils s'exprime il s'exprime
assez largement en connaissance de cause
très difficile au fond de cacher
la vérité ce qu'on est
à
aux électeurs dans une campagne dans une
campagne électorale
peut-être que je suis trop confiant dans
la nature humaine mais c'est ma
conviction
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre notre
collègue doit nous quitter donc monsieur
ménager je vous ferai passer après ça
nous ennuie pas la parole est à Nadège
avant Mongolie merci le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous l'avez
évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure un
rapport avait été remis en 2012 au
président de la République Nicolas
Sarkozy qui appelait dans ses
conclusions a créé un espace économique
commun entre la Russie et l'Union
européenne vous avez rappelé que ça
avait pas été très bien reçu à l'époque
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Thomas ancien
député des Vosges reconverti dans le
privé est-elle au tort de ce rapport
enfin il s'était vu confié la rédaction
de ce rapport il a par la suite était
nommée en 2018 président du conseil
d'administration du groupe russe Russell
qui est leader mondial de la production
d'aluminium elle n'est plus en poste
depuis 2019 dit-on à la suite de
pression américaine comme quoi ça peut
venir un peu de partout ces activités
peuvent-elles à votre avis questionner
la sincérité du coup du rapport qui
avait été remis par Monsieur Thomas en
2012 finalement ce rapport pourrait
presque apparaître comme une lettre de
motivation avant embauche bon ça c'est
la première de mes questions deuxième
question en tant qu'ensein Premier
ministre au fait des affaires de l'État
et au fait de la politique étrangère de
pensez-vous pas quand même que la
reconversion de haut cadre administratif
ou politique d'élus français auprès
d'entreprises étrangères notamment quand
ces entreprises sont fortement adossés à
l'état il y a des entreprises états on
le sait n'est pas préjudiciable à notre
politique étrangère pensez vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure en fait les
conditions qui pour vous sont centrales
qui est qui sont la nature des relations
diplomatiques
est-ce qu'il y a pas quand même d'autres
éléments est-ce que c'est suffisant vous
avez évoqué la Russie qui en guerre
contre l'Ukraine et donc contre l'un de
nos alliés n'est-il pas d'autres
conditions par exemple la nature des
activités ou bien un délai de carence
conséquent après la fin des activités
publiques je vous remercie
sur le premier sujet l'idée d'un espace
économique
avec la Russie et bien antérieure à 2012
c'était une idée que le président
Sarkozy a mis sur la table en 2008
lorsqu'il était lorsqu'il présidait
l'Union européenne
honnêtement je me souviens pas du
rapport de Monsieur Thomas mais en 2012
c'était un peu tard pour pour réaliser
l'opération
au fond il y avait deux philosophies il
y a la philosophie qui consiste qui qui
à dire plus on va aider la Russie à se
développer
plus il y aura d'aspiration
peut-être pas à la démocratie mais en
tout cas à une
comment dirais-je à une vie politique et
sociale plus plus plus libre et plus
apaisé et puis ceux qui considèrent que
il y a rien à faire avec la Russie et
donc
on refait la guerre froide jusqu'à la
fin des temps nous on considérait qu'il
y avait une voix
et je pense sincèrement que il y a un
président Poutine avant et un président
Poutine après il y a un président
Poutine qui a un moment
né est obnubilé par le développement
économique de son pays
et ça correspond à la période que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure après
ces résultats économiques n'étant sans
doute pas très performant le temps
passant parce que il y a quelque chose
qui est très important dans les dans les
régimes autoritaires c'est le temps
c'est à dire que
les Chinois avaient inventé un système
le Parti communiste chinois avait
inventer un système qui était assez
intelligent qui consistait à limiter à
deux mandats le mandat du président
chinois
et le président chinois savait que au
bout de deux mandat
il aurait une fin de vie confortable
dans une jolie maison au bord de la mer
et dans des bonnes conditions
le président occitan a mis fin à ce
système je pense que c'est une assez
grave erreur parce que le problème du du
dirigeant autoritaire c'est que plus le
temps va passer
plus sa sortie du pouvoir devient
impossible hypothétique
dangereuse et donc c'est pour ça que
il peut y avoir eu une évolution dans le
caractère et le comportement du
dirigeant russe lié à cette question du
du temps
sur le deuxième sujet je vous ai répondu
déjà j'ai déjà répondu je considère que
on est dans un monde ouvert
tant qu'on respecte les règles
il y a aucune raison d'empêcher des
responsables parce qu'ils ont eu un
moment donné une activité publique
d'exercer des fonctions privées à
condition naturellement que ça soit pas
dans des entreprises qui soient des
entreprises qui constituent d'une
manière ou d'une autre une menace pour
l'indépendance nationale donc bah oui
c'est là il y a des il peut y avoir des
sujets
on n'a pas évoqué par exemple vous
n'avez personne à poser de questions sur
le la la faire des bateaux que nous
avions décidé de vendre à la Russie par
exemple moi j'ai toujours défendu en
tant que Premier ministre une politique
consistant à ne pas vendre des systèmes
d'armes sophistiqués à des pays
dangereux
le mistral n'était pas un système d'arme
sophistiqué en revanche je me suis
opposé par exemple à la vente de
sous-marin à certains pays parce que je
considère que moins il y a de sous-marin
sous les océans mieux je me porte et
mieux la sécurité de mon pays est
assurée donc ça c'est évidemment un
élément important et puis et puis après
où on est en paix où on n'est pas en
paix on peut pas
découper de cette manière comme on le
fait avec les sanctions d'ailleurs d'une
certaine façon découper
en essayant de ménager nos intérêts ceux
qui peut être imposé ce qui ne peut pas
être imposé
je suis pas personne m'a interrogé sur
les sanctions mais vous savez que je
suis totalement hostile aux sanctions et
que je pense que les sanctions c'est
j'y suis aussi pour trois raisons la
première raison c'est que ça n'a jamais
marché il y a pas un seul exemple dans
le monde d'un pays important qui est
baissé la tête parce qu'on lui imposé
les sanctions économiques ça n'existe
pas comment ouais c'est pas les
sanctions qui ont fait baisser l'Afrique
du Sud c'est c'est la situation
intérieure qui a fait baisser le
l'exemple de Cuba est assez intéressant
ça dure depuis combien de temps il y a
une deuxième raison pour laquelle je
suis aussi aux sanctions c'est qu'elles
ont des répercussions sur notre économie
qui sont assez désastreuses et pas
forcément des répercussions aussi graves
qu'on le dit sur l'économie d'en face
j'ai vu en Russie entre 2014 et
jusque jusqu'en 2020 comment tout un pan
de l'économie russe c'est créer pour
répondre aux sanctions voilà autrefois
on faisait pas de fromage en Russie
maintenant on fait des fromages en
Russie autrefois on faisait pratiquement
pas de viande bovine en Russie
maintenant on fait de la viande bovine
en Russie je prends ces deux exemplaires
mais il y en a plein d'autres mais il y
a un troisième une troisième raison qui
est encore beaucoup plus grave que tout
que tout le reste c'est que les
sanctions elles viennent toujours du
même endroit elles viennent des
États-Unis et de l'Europe c'est les
Occidentaux qui imposent leur sanctions
aux autres pays du au reste du monde et
si vous ne ressentez pas à quel point
cette politique là fait monter dans le
monde un ressentiment contre nous contre
les Occidentaux mais vous ne voyez pas
arriver l'orage qui va malheureusement
s'abattre à un moment donné sur l'Europe
et l'Occident si nous ne sommes pas
capables de de comprendre que on ne peut
plus parler au reste du monde comme si
on était les maîtres de la classe
on a le devoir
de faire preuve d'un tout petit peu plus
de compréhension et de et de tact dans
notre manière de traiter le reste du
monde pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il
y a une immense majorité de la
population mondiale qui réside dans des
pays qui ne sont pas hostiles à la
guerre en Ukraine ou en tout cas qui ne
s'associe pas aux sanctions c'est pas
parce que ces pays soutiennent la Russie
c'est parce que ces pays ne supportent
plus
ce qu'il considère comme une forme
d'arrogance qui est le fait que des pays
riches imposent à des pays plus pauvres
des sanctions économiques
réponse mais du coup moi j'avais parlé à
un moment donné de nature des activités
juste du coup une question très simple
vous avez parlé de défense d'industrie
de la défense est-ce que vous considérez
normal par exemple qu'un ancien ministre
de la Défense puisse travailler dans une
entreprise étrangère
qui parle qui qui traite d'industrie de
la défense en fait voilà on a
responsable politique européen qui
travaille dans des entreprises de
défense américaine sans doute russe non
je pense pas d'ailleurs les Russes n'en
voudraient pas
non non mais bien sûr il y a des
secteurs qui sont des secteurs
stratégiques c'est ce que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure
merci Monsieur prémistes paroles
Monsieur Thomas mennel merci Monsieur
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
alors j'aurais deux questions assez
rapides mais qui font suite à votre
exposé la première c'est la question du
financement vous avez dit clairement
qu'il était pour vous impossible
aujourd'hui que une puissance étrangère
finance une campagne électorale vous
avez dit par contre par le passé c'était
possible à quel moment vous vous avez
considéré qu'il y avait eu une bascule
quelqu'un passer vous aviez en tête
quand vous expliquez cela voilà
aujourd'hui la sncfp permet un contrôle
tel que il est impossible et c'est vrai
quand on a participé à l'élection
présidentielle quand on a regardé un
compte de campagne et quand on sait le
contrôle actuel on est on peut
difficilement imaginer qu'une puissance
étrangère puisse financer une campagne
mais j'aimerais savoir à quel moment
vous jugez que cette les méthodes et la
moralisation ont permis de faire évoluer
ces pratiques et la deuxième question
vous avez parlé de d'articles orientés
d'articles Médiatis vous avez parlé de
manipulation soft de l'information si
j'ai bien entendu est-ce que vous
considérez qu'aujourd'hui la question
des ingérences la question qu'on traite
dans cette commission est utilisée
politique ment pour salir pour nuire et
souvent sans fondement et pour
participer en fait à des cabales
médiatiques contraint un certain nombre
de d'opposants politiques
ce que j'ai voulu dire tout à l'heure
c'est que un article est sorti me
concernant qui si vous le lisez vous
donne le sentiment qu'il y a une enquête
qui est ouverte contre moi
concernant des sujets en Russie
heureusement il y a quelques
journalistes
à la suite de cet article qui ont dû à
les pousser un peu plus loin
l'investigation et qui ont conclu qu'il
n'y avait pas d'enquête ouverte entre
moi sur ce sujet voilà mais une fois que
le titre est
sur les réseaux sociaux voilà c'est
c'est comme ça mais enfin je vis avec ça
depuis maintenant un certain nombre
d'années donc
je vais pas aggraver mon cas en faisant
des commentaires qui se retourneront
contre moi sur le
financement il y a eu toute une série de
d'étapes qui ont conduit à comment
dirais-je encadré moraliser le
financement des campagnes électorales
donc ça commence grosso modo
milieu des années 80
avant il y a quasiment zéro règle
c'est l'époque de l'argent liquide
puis il y a ensuite la les premières
décisions en matière de transparence la
limitation des dons
et je pense qu'on est arrivé aujourd'hui
à un système qui est d'une extrême
rigueur
c'est pour ça que je disais tout à
l'heure que je vois pas comment un parti
politique ou un candidat à une élection
présidentielle peut
intégrer des financements non non
autorisés dans ces contes de campagne
quand on voit la le degré de précision
dans lequel la Haute autorité ou la
Commission des comptes de campagne
rentre puisqu'elle est elle va analyser
les je sais pas moi les factures de
d'imprimerie pour voir si les tarifs qui
sont pratiqués sont des tarifs normaux
donc je voilà je vois pas du tout alors
c'est un système qui est très spécial à
la France on est un des pays les plus
rigoureux je pense je connais pas les
pays d'Europe du Nord mais aux
États-Unis c'est pas comme ça aux
États-Unis on peut financer sans limite
c'est simplement transparent
pour précision de Monsieur thomannier
vous considérez que en 2012 quand vous
quittez Matignon l'état la législation
protège les partis politiques et
personnalités politiques nous démocratie
du financement des trois quarts pardon
où est-ce que vous estimez que c'est
ensuite que la législation le permet
législation a été durcie c'est
incontestable mais déjà je pense qu'en
la législation est très claire
c'est-à-dire le montant des des
participations et limitées
la commission
chacun se souvient du sort qui a été
celui des contes de campagne de 2000 du
président Sarkozy en 2012 donc la
Commission va très très loin dans son
dans son dans son analyse
donc je pense que oui en 2012 c'est
quasiment impossible que de l'argent
provenant d'un pays étranger
servent de manière significative
financer une campagne
merci monsieur le Premier j'aurai
quelques questions je n'ai pas posé à
mon premier tour pour que la parole
puisse circuler lors de votre exposé
luminaire vous avez évoqué différentes
différents sujets c'est vrai que les
questions se sont concentrées s'il
n'était pas exclusive sur la question de
l'ingérence russe je voudrais revenir à
ce que vous avez évoqué des inférences
que vous avez eu à connaître et à
traiter et à lutter j'imagine contre
quand vous étiez Premier ministre
notamment l'affaire des écoutes donc
vous avez mentionné le fait que la
presse de mémoire a révélé des écoutes
opérer par les États-Unis la NSC sur un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques de pays alliés mentionné la
France il y a aussi eu de mémoire
l'Allemagne qui avait fait grand bruit
grand bruit c'est le budget de ma
question pas tellement quand on fait des
recherches évidemment en tant que
président de la commission qu'on est
faite sur ce dossier on trouve
finalement peu de suite en tout cas
public à
écoute est-ce que dans le respect
évidemment du secret défense mais pour
la bonne information de la
représentation nationale
compte tenu du peu d'informations que
public qu'il y a que nous disposons sur
cette affaire est-ce que vous pouvez
nous exposer quelle mesure ont été
prises par votre gouvernement quand ces
écoutes ont été connus est-ce qu'elles
étaient d'ailleurs peut-être connus de
votre gouvernement avant que ce soit
soyons informés par des voix publiques
et est-ce que vous avez envisagé
peut-être
des adaptations législatives ou
technologiques qui permettent de
protéger notre pays de ses écoutes
donc quand les écoutes ont été révélés
nous n'étions plus nous n'étions plus
aux affaires la vérité c'est que tout le
monde trouve ça normal voilà c'est vous
l'avez vous l'avez très bien dit tout le
monde trouve ça normal parce que ça
vient de nos amis américains et donc ça
fait partie des choses qui sont c'est
dans la nature des choses et ça n'a
suscité que deux ou trois jours de
commentaires
et je pense que personne n'a pris une
mesure pour sécuriser les communications
téléphoniques des membres du
gouvernement par exemple
le président Sarkozy et moi-même nous
n'avons jamais utilisé autre chose que
nos téléphones portables
nous a donné un moment des téléphones
cryptés qui étaient tellement compliqués
à utiliser qu'on les a jamais utilisés
j'avais un moment souhaité qu'on
interdise les téléphones dans certaines
enceintes notamment au Conseil des
ministres et je n'avais pas réussi à
convaincre donc même au Conseil des
ministres il y a des téléphones pas il y
avait des téléphones portables et donc
ça veut dire que n'importe qui pouvait
écouter n'importe quoi je pense que
c'est un vrai sujet qui mériterait
d'être beaucoup plus rigoureux beaucoup
plus attentif
j'écoutais sur une
radio une télévision d'information
commentaire sur le fait qu'il y a de
plus en plus d'antennes sur les toits
des ambassades russes la belle affaire
il y a pas d'antenne sur les doigts des
ambassades américaines faut juste aller
regarder à celle qui est juste à côté
d'ici et puis sur les toits des
ambassades françaises enfin j'irais tout
le monde écoute tout le monde
on le sait
et je pense qu'on s'en protège pas assez
la réponse qu'on vient de m'apporter je
dois dire à croire mon inquiétude plus
que je me permets de reposer la question
justement en tant que Premier ministre
quand vous êtes un conseil des ministres
quand vous dirigez l'action de
gouvernement quand on connaît c'est pas
du tout ironique vos convictions votre
parcours et l'idéologie et votre de
votre engagement justement le fait que
vous constatez que les téléphones
cryptés ne sont pas utilisés ou sont
trop compliqués à utiliser dans un
contexte on est quand même après le 11
septembre on connaît déjà l'Empire
l'ampleur des systèmes d'information et
des et des coups de renseignements que
la puisse que les États-Unis mettent en
place d'ailleurs en lien avec d'autres
alliés on connaîtration le Royaume-Uni
l'Australie bon de l'autre côté
évidemment d'autres puissances qui ne
sont pas nos alliés qui sont plus
directement hostiles ou qu'aurai pu être
hostile mène les mêmes les mêmes
procédés donc c'est vrai qu'on a du mal
à comprendre ça fait maintenant 5 mois
que nous travaillons en tout cas moi je
je persiste à être étonné parfois de
fait que plusieurs responsable politique
ou d'être d'administration constate de
tels manquements qui semble penser
évident comme un des mortels sans que
une fois plus c'est une question ouverte
il ne semble pas que des dispositions
même basiques et étaient prises
et des prises pour contrer c'est évident
non je pense que c'est un problème
culturel on n'a pas
on n'arrive pas dans le secteur public à
prendre on n'arrive pas peut-être que
les choses changent aujourd'hui à
prendre la mesure de cette menace j'ai
constaté dans mes activités notamment
lorsque j'étais associé de ce fonds
d'investissement que la rigueur a été
beaucoup plus grande
s'agissant des téléphones de l'usage des
mets etc dans le secteur privé peut-être
que c'est dû à aussi à la
comment dire à la
une certaine un caractère assez
bureaucratique du système de sécurité
qu'on met en place et quand vous êtes
ministre et que un officier des services
vient vous expliquer que il faut pas
utiliser Internet faut pas envoyer de
mail faut pas aller sur les réseaux
sociaux etc
voilà vous avez tendance à écouter d'une
oreille et à faire le contraire ensuite
peut-être qu'il faudrait avoir des
équipes plus technologiques au sens plus
plus
au fait plus plus plus moderne dans
l'usage des technologies parce que on
peut pas imposer dans une société comme
celle d'aujourd'hui
l'absence totale de d'utilisation des
réseaux etc ce qui est un peu la
tendance des services quand je me
souviens que la première fois que j'ai
installé dans un bureau ministériel je
crois que c'était au Télécom une borne
Wi-Fi sans prévenir les services de
sécurité j'ai vu des boulets dans mon
bureau tout d'un coup quatre ou cinq
officiers
persuadé quelqu'un venait d'installer un
système pirate dans le dans le dans le
ministère et ils avaient raison c'était
pas raisonnable de ma part d'avoir fait
ça mais
je crois que c'est un vrai problème de
culture et qui passe par
la mise en place de systèmes
technologique qui soit pas trop
restreignant enfin qui soit pas trop
contraignants qui permettent quand même
de
aux responsables politiques de rester
branchés si je puis dire mais il y a un
vrai sujet oui
merci monsieur le Premier vous avez
évoqué de parler dans votre expo dans
votre exposé
liminaire le droit d'être
extraterritorial américain comme moyen
d'influence ou d'ingérence
effectivement entre 2012 et 2017 un
certain nombre d'entreprises ont eu à
connaître de ces tentatives d'ingérence
d'ailleurs de mémoire vous en avez
d'ailleurs fait aussi un axe non pas
central mais quand même assez notable de
votre programme politique pour
l'élection de 2017 et donc ma question
est assez simple de la même façon que je
vous ai posé la question sur le les
écoutes monsieur Montebourg a témoigné
dans une autre audition enfin dans deux
auditions il est dans le même sens il a
été cohérent avec lui-même si je puis
dire sur le fait que l'intelligence
économique française pour alerter les
décideurs politiques français sur les
tentatives d'ingérence en matière
économique ou dans des des
investissements stratégiques à ses yeux
dysfonctionnés gravement qu'on peut se
dire
en 2012 quand il est arrivé quand il est
arrivé à Bercy donc vous même en tant
que Premier ministre que vous avez été
alerté sur est-ce que vous partagez les
inquiétudes enfin le constat de Monsieur
Montebourg sur l'état de l'intelligence
économique en 2012 et ce que votre
premier ministre était un sujet
d'inquiétude est-ce que vous avez si
c'était un sujet d'inquiétude tenter de
l'améliorer
c'est beaucoup plus grave qu'un la
question de l'intelligence économique
c'est c'est tout à fait inacceptable
qu'un pays fut-il notre meilleur allié
se permettre de sanctionner de mettre
sous contrôle de mettre sous monitoring
des entreprises qui ne sont pas des
entreprises qui dépendent de son de sa
souveraineté
j'ai cherché tous les moyens de lutter
contre cette affaire alors il y a un
premier qui consistrait à ce que les
Européens se fâchent et
fasse un bras de fer avec les États-Unis
sur ce sujet sauf que c'est pas possible
puisque une grande partie des Européens
ne feront jamais de bras de fer avec les
Américains
ensuite il y a une autre il y avait une
deuxième formule qui est celle que
j'avais retenue mais qui je reconnais un
peu
ambitieuse voir utopique qui était de
faire de l'euro une monnaie
internationale
c'est que moi j'ai voté contre la
monnaie unique et je me souviens que
dans le débat sur la monnaie unique l'un
des arguments qui étaient mis en avant
par les défenseurs de la monnaie unique
c'était justement qu'on puisse avoir un
jour une monnaie qui soit l'équivalent
du dollar bah non on n'a jamais eu une
monnaie qui soit l'équivalent du dollars
j'avais réuni un petit groupe de travail
pour voir comment faire de l'euro une
monnaie internationale il y avait Michel
kans dessus il y avait un certain nombre
de gens qui avaient eu des
responsabilités financières imminentes
et on avait bâti un projet et j'ai fait
le tour des ministres des Finances
européens c'était après
2013 ou 14
j'ai reçu un accueil relativement poli à
peu près partout sauf en Allemagne
quand j'ai été présenté à monsieur
chaudeleux mon projet de
faire de l'euro une monnaie
internationale il m'a dit tu as
parfaitement raison mais on le fera
jamais
et il m'a dit on le fera jamais parce
que les Américains assurent notre
sécurité nous défendent enfin je me suis
dit à ce moment la dit j'avais que
j'avais pas intégré cette cette
dimension dans le donc oui cette
question elle est elle est vraiment
insupportable parce que j'ai cité
exemple de la BNP tout à l'heure
la BNP quand j'ai interrogé les
dirigeants de la BNP en disant mais
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
libéré en dollars des transactions avec
le Soudan que vous auriez très bien pu
les libérer les libellés en euros et à
ce moment-là ils m'ont dit non mais si
on libère des transactions en euros nous
aurons immédiatement des mesures de
rétention aux États-Unis et comme on est
une banque mondiale et internationale on
peut pas se permettre d'avoir
une hostilité américaine à notre égard
les mesures contre Airbus
peut toujours dire qu'il y a tel ou
telle raison qui ont poussé
l'administration américaine à s'en
prendre à Airbus mais enfin on remarque
que c'est quand même toujours
à un moment où il y a une compétition
entre une grande entreprise américaine
et une grande entreprise européenne et
ou comme par hasard c'est l'entreprise
européenne qui se prend les sanctions
les accusations de corruption etc
on peut pas ne pas penser qu'il y a dans
le la démarche américaine pas seulement
une volonté de rigueur et de et de
d'éthique mais qui a une volonté de
favoriser les entreprises américaines et
l'économie américaine et puis d'une
façon générale c'est tout à fait
insupportable de penser que des pays
européens sont piés poignées devant
cette cette situation
malheureusement je vous apporte pas de
solution puisque la solution de la
monnaie
du fin de l'euro internationale et
semble maintenant s'éloigner et quant à
l'idée que l'Europe pourrait exercer une
vraie pression sur les États-Unis et
avec des rétorsions
elle est absolument illusoire puisqu'il
l'Allemagne ne l'acceptera jamais la
Pologne n'acceptera jamais etc
enfin en tout cas
à horizon visible
merci Monsieur Je me permets de
repréciser ma question en fait ces
auditions nos auditions nous ont montré
qu'un certain nombre de mesures
notamment la loi Sapin versant de
dispositions qui ont été prises par
gouvernement précédent le premier mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron puis justement
renforcer et ce sera l'appréciation
évidemment de du rapport de la
commission mais on peut grandement
améliorer justement la situation entre
ce que Monsieur Montebourg a constaté en
2012 et la situation présentant je peux
pas et comme de reposer une deuxième
fois ma question ou en tant que Premier
ministre est-ce que même si je comprends
que vous avez répondu que ça allait
au-delà l'intelligence économique mais
j'aimerais quand même avoir votre
opinion sur cette notion honnêtement
d'intelligence économique est-ce que je
sais pas le souvenir qu'on ait été très
très actif sur ce sujet là donc je je
j'accepte tout à fait l'idée qui est
depuis des progrès de fait en matière
d'intelligence économique
question subséquente une des faiblesses
en tout cas des failles qui a été
utilisées par le droit extra-territorial
américain et des pratiques de corruption
d'un certain nombre d'entreprises
françaises qui ont là aussi entendu dans
d'autres auditions étaient peut-être
exagérées sur le peut être ce n'est pas
moi de le juger de la part de droit
américain mais qui existait quand même
qui n'était pas non plus des faits de
corruption imaginés ou inventés dans nos
auditions nous avons pu comprendre que
la Bercy même il y avait un bureau qui
n'ont pas organisé évidemment mais enfin
qui était au courant d'un certain nombre
de pratiques
qu'on peut estimer quand même fondament
du point de vue moral ou même éthique
l'entreprise excusez-moi monsieur le
Premier ma question d'un point de vue
moral ou éthique qui avait connaissance
de ces diverses formes de pratiques
assimilables ou assimilées à de la
corruption et c'est vrai qu'on peut
s'interroger sur le fait que l'État
français les gouvernements successifs
d'ailleurs évidemment pas seulement
celui que vous avez dirigé on
semble-t-il peut-être d'ailleurs je ne
sais pas si vous le saviez vous
l'ignorez l'existence de service
on laissait quand même prospérer
c'est pratique alors que la législation
américaine était assez claire depuis les
années 70 il y a une immense hypocrisie
américaine parce que les entreprises
américaines se livrent exactement au
même pratique c'est ça le sujet c'est
pour ça que je ne dis pas que il faut
pas lutter contre la corruption je dis
que c'est pas aux Américains d'imposer
leurs règles en matière de corruption
aux entreprises européennes et c'est pas
aux Européens d'imposer des leurs
entreprises américaines voilà c'est ça
mon point
oui pour vendre des avions
Boeing a certainement dans le passé
ou pour vendre des systèmes d'armes à
certainement utilisé des méthodes qui
sont condamnables et des entreprises
européennes ont fait la même chose c'est
au gouvernement européen c'est au
gouvernement français de combattre ces
pratiques ce qui est pas acceptable
c'est que ce soit un gouvernement
étranger qui nous impose
ces règles pourquoi parce que vous ne
pourrez jamais être sûr que ce gouver ce
gouvernement étranger est sincère
et qu'il agit en l'occurrence uniquement
pour combattre la corruption et pas pour
faire tomber une entreprise européenne
qui le gène et le fait qu'il y ait eu
une grande concentration
des
sanctions américaines sur des grandes
entreprises françaises qui étaient en
situation de concurrence avec des grands
entreprises américaines et quand même
troublant c'est ça que je veux dire
je vous remercie dans votre exposé votre
introduction vous avez aussi mentionné
attentative des réalités d'ingérence
provenant si ma liste est bonne au moins
de la Turquie du Maroc de l'Algérie avec
des consignes de vote qui était donnés
est-ce que vous pourriez développer ce
point et pareil est-ce que sous votre
gouvernement des mesures ont été prises
pour contrer limiter ou
empêcher cette forme référence c'est
dans cet esprit là que nous avions
entrepris la création du
Conseil du culte musulman c'était pour
essayer de faire en sorte que
s'agissant de la religion musulmane
elle puisse échapper progressivement à
l'influence de ces parrains qui suivant
les nuances de cette religion sont la
Turquie le Maroc et l'Algérie et oui
bien sûr on a assisté à des à des on a
on a vu de façon très précise des
consignes de vote donnée
par les turcs ou par les Algériens ou
par les Marocains à travers leur
responsables religieux et c'était la
réponse qu'on a essayé de d'articuler
c'était le conseil du culte musulman je
dis pas que le résultat était
remarquable mais en tout cas il faut
déjà c'est important déjà d'être
conscient que ça existe
et là je trouve que le l'ingérance elle
est directe elle est pas elle est pas
fantaisiste elle est pas à travers je ne
sais quel réseau social elle est direct
c'est des instructions de vote
merci pour la bonne compréhension en
tout cas de la personne et de ce que je
pense qu'il nous écoutent quand vous
parlez de consignes de votre
c'est-à-dire que ces gouvernements
étrangers
à travers leurs réseaux
d'imam donne des consignes de vote à
toutes les élections
c'est à toutes les élections françaises
c'est à dire à la fois des consignes de
vote pour les élections on va dire pour
celles qui sont les plus importantes
municipales présidentielles et
législative par exemple est-ce qu'elle
favorise un parti parmi d'autres ou
est-ce que c'est ça tourne il y a eu des
consignes de vote au niveau local
il y a eu des consignes de vote alors
ils sont parfois elles peuvent annuler
parce que ce sont pas les mêmes
les mêmes obédiences mais il y avait des
consignes votes au niveau local au
niveau national des consignes de vote
pour des parties qui étaient plus
favorables ou qui semblaient plus
favorables aux cultes musulmans et donc
ce sont des ingérences qui sont
considérables compte tenues du nombre de
personnes
sensibles ou qui pouvaient à l'époque
être sensibles à ces consignes de vote
c'est-à-dire le nombre de ressortissants
d'anciens ressortissants ou de personnes
ayant une attache avec ces pays
merci mais justement je dois dire que
cette information quand même
préoccupe est-ce que vous avez en tant
que Premier ministre c'est ce que vous
avez quantifié cette influence est-ce
que nos services sont quantifiés est-ce
que on peut est-ce qu'à un moment on
s'est interrogé vous êtes interrogé avec
votre gouvernement sur le fait qu'ils
sont certains territoires peut-être ou
ces populations sensibles assez
consignes de vote étaient importantes
que des élections de notre République et
puis aller dans un sens ou dans l'autre
parce que des contenus excusez il faut
vraiment que je puisse finir mes
questions que donc c'est consignes de
vote qui ont été données donc par des
gouvernements étrangers à travers des
réseaux religieux est-ce qu'il y a des
dans votre connaissance des territoires
de la République peut-être des
municipalités qui ont pu aller dans un
déliction sur notre territoire qui sont
serrés un certain nombre de territoires
qui auraient pu basculer d'un sens à
l'autre parce que des consignes de vote
depuis l'étranger ont été donnés
non je suis pas capable de répondre à
cette question je suis pas capable de
quantifier les choses et je veux pas
m'aventurer sur des terrains sur lequel
je suis pas je n'ai pas suffisamment
d'éléments mais ce qui était ce à quoi
beaucoup d'élus locaux qui j'imagine
sont ici ont été confrontés c'est quand
même à des à la gestion de certains de
certaines mosquées pour dire les choses
dépendant de certains États
qui posaient problème et c'est pour ça
que nous avons pris des mesures pour
essayer de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
moins d'ingérence étrangère dans la
gestion des lieux de culte qu'on a créé
le conseil du culte musulman et qu'on a
essayé de bâtir ce qu'on appelait
l'islam
l'islam français ou l'islam de France
après je suis incapable de mesurer
les conséquences de ces ingérences
simplement je dis qu'elles sont elles
sont connues elles sont pas c'est pas
moi qui vous apprends ça aujourd'hui
c'est c'est c'est
ce sont des des faits qui sont
parfaitement documentés
et sur lequel il y a une littérature
merci monsieur le Premier ma dernière
question sera
une question à être là été posée
là-dessus mais la réponse ne m'a pas
paru complète par rapport à l'enjeu de
cette commission vous avez évoqué donc
des articles de presse qui peuvent
paraître il y a 6000 qui font des
assimilations par capillarité par des
titres choisis qui peuvent être donc qui
peuvent renvoyer un article donc contenu
est en fait assez différent contenu qui
d'ailleurs parfois n'est pas accessible
donc le titre est accessible par le plus
grand nombre et le contenu qui peut dire
l'inverse en tout cas nuancer le titre
ne l'est pas on peut considérer que la
diffusion de ce genre d'articles peut
avoir une influence sur le processus
électoraux tout simplement sur la bonne
information de nos concitoyens ou de
leur ou de leur relais vous avez dit
vous ne souhaitiez pas faire des
déclarations supplémentaires vous avez
c'est évidemment votre droit mais quand
même avec l'expérience que vous avez de
la vie politique française son évolution
aussi dans le temps
une différence de pratique d'évolution
de la manière dont les campagnes sont
faites
[Musique]
un regard rapide sur les élections de
ces 20 dernières années on remarque ça
va peut-être période de tension
électorale
un certain nombre de partis politiques
tous ont plus ou moins été frappés
certains sont accusés d'être favorable à
la Russie certains favorables aux
États-Unis
ou des noms d'oiseaux sont des soupçons
sont invoquer envers des personnalités
engagées est-ce que pour vous c'est une
pratique qui a toujours existé est-ce
que c'est une pratique qui a fait des
allers-retours et ce que dans les où
est-ce que pour vous c'est une pratique
qui existe ou est-ce que ce que la
question que je pose d'ailleurs n'est
pour vous pas pertinente ou relève pas
d'observation sérieuse bref voilà est-ce
que le évidemment cette commission
s'occupe de réalité des risques
d'ingérence sur notre démocratie mais
aussi de la possibilité que ces risques
c'est arrêté d'ingérence soient
elles-mêmes utilisées pour aussi
manipuler l'opinion dans l'autre sens
ils ont toujours existé c'est pratique
là ils ont toujours existé
dans les campagnes électorales
d'autrefois on attaquait en accusé les
communistes d'être aux ordres de Moscou
les centristes d'être payés par
Washington simplement alors je réponds
prudemment parce que j'ai pris du recul
et je suis pas au cœur des choses comme
vous l'êtes et donc peut-être que mon
appréciation est
pas totalement pertinente mais je pense
que dans ces époques il y avait il y
avait des il y avait une presse plus
contradictoire
là on a le sentiment que sur un certain
nombre de sujets c'est quasiment unanime
c'est à dire que le papier qui va sortir
à 8h
d'un journal il va se propager toute la
journée sur toutes les chaînes d'impôts
surtout les réseaux sociaux surtout et
avec une certaine forme d'une anémie et
c'est ça que je trouve gênant si je
prends l'exemple de la crise de la
guerre en Ukraine et de la situation en
Europe
je lis beaucoup la presse américaine je
suis frappé de voir que il y a une aux
États-Unis un débat paradoxalement dans
le pays qui est le plus engagé dans le
combat contre la Russie il y a un débat
beaucoup plus ouvert il y a des gens qui
donnent des arguments pour des arguments
contre
chez nous j'ai beau chercher
c'est c'est uneanime et c'est jamais bon
quand c'est unanime en disant ça je
porte pas de jugement sur sur le conflit
je dis que c'est jamais bon quand la
totalité d'un système médiatique ou la
quasi-totalité d'un système médiatique
défend une seule thèse
et c'est ça que peut-être qui est plus
grave aujourd'hui que ce que j'ai pu
connaître dans le passé c'est à dire
qu'autrefois il y avait un débat
contradictoire violent
mais chacun allait vers le média dans
lequel il avait confiance et dont il
pensait qu'il défendait ses idées
aujourd'hui sur un certain nombre de
sujets pas surtout mais sur un certain
nombre de sujets
et notamment sur ce que vous avez évoqué
sur ces attaques ces accusations de
partie qui serait vendues à je ne sais
quelle puissance étrangère il y a une
certaine forme d'une illimité
je vous remercie que les questions des
commissaires d'un rapporteur très bien
monsieur prémil je vous remercie du
temps que vous avez consacré à notre
audition